I got to see I got to see this. How do we get here?
And the general sentiment is
ain't no way this story is true. >> But she was literally
asking for it so badly that we can't prosecute it. Okay, that's
that's his position.
>> We have a necessary minimum on Okay, there is a necessary
minimum. I don't know. Where does this transition into how Lauren
soped him? Cuz like he says these are all real conversations,
right? But how did this turn into like the part where she sighed
him? How did she get him talking to an account she
It's so not hard to get any of the facts on this before you comment.
It's so easy to not sound like a idiot here, dude.
Got not just tweets. I've also got clips, videos. Is that Ethan?
That's Darius. That's Darius's mugsh shot. I don't know why somebody
did this. Okay. I don't know. I don't understand. But I
support the people who do it. Okay.
Support them automatically. All right. So, Andrew Lawyer, Andrew
Lawyer, Andrew Tate's lawyer apparently made a statement today.
Now,
I don't know.
I don't know if uh he totally I don't know if Andrew Tate is
really this guy's lawyer. I don't know. But we'll see. Let's
just give it a quick read. statement on behalf of Andrew Tate
regarding Lauren Southern's false allegations. Andrew Tate unequivocally
repudiates the pathetic filth pedled by Lauren Southern in her
pitiable tome. Oh god. Oh god. He's going to wordsmith this.
This is not real life. A washed up nobody loser memoir if there
ever was one. No evidence supports their claims. The Oh, look.
You're never It's never going to not be amusing to me how this
like totally will follow. One to one analogous with the DGG stuff,
right? Like it's just one to one analogous. It's very funny to
me. Unfortunately,
it's it's not I don't by the way I don't agree with it. In either
case, I don't hate Lauren Southern enough to to like try to make
this not a valid thing or not a reasonable like uh accusation
she's making. Tracks very closely. The the rhetoric will be very
similar. The so-called free chapter release is nothing but an
evil marketing ploy. A sensational teaser engineered to propel
sales of her book by parasetizing Andrew's fame. Southern is
a faded relic, destitute and desperate, scavenging scraps of
relevance and revenue from Andrew's renown. We've witnessed this
wretched ploy countless times, stale and cippid, utterly contemptable.
We shall pursue Southern relentlessly for defamation. Her abject
lack of proof and shattered credibility will seal our inevitable
triumph. Yet this assault and its ilk threaten every man breathing.
They targeted Trump, then Tate, mark my words, you are in the
crosshairs next. Dude, they're coming for men everywhere. And
Andrew Tate is just in the way. Okay, they're coming for you.
And Andrew Tate is in the way. He's standing in front. Okay,
he is the shield that defends men. He is He is the shield that
guards the realms of men. Okay, he's the Night Watch. All right,
men. This is the playbook to destroy your life. Turn consensual
into non-consentual via retroactive accusations weaponized for
extortion, lawsuits, and payouts. No man, husband, father, son
is safe from this venom where mutual encounters become traps
for financial ruin.
Dude, they're hitting all the points. They're hitting all the
points. This is a clarion call to men everywhere. The war rages
with false accusations weaponized to shatter lives, twisting
consensual bonds into extortion snares. Everything is on the
line. Rise now. Demand proof. Unmask the deceivers. Forge unity
in courts of law and public opinion. Fight the unyielding or
sorry, fight with unyielding truth or forfeit all. Everything
is on the line. These people think they're in Lord of the Rings.
Actually, these people think that like they're a bunch of they're
a bunch of 30-year-old women at the gates of Helm's Deep right
now. Okay. And these guys believe that they are the last of the
Roherim. They're about to ride out. All right. To save Andrew
Tate to prove that this man who's declared that he basically
chokes women. He does. Women love this. Yeah, we we do this kind
of play all the time. Yeah, I scam women out of everything. Yeah,
I've I've been accused of assault multiple times. Yeah, I've
been uh I've like trafficked women. Yes, I I talk about lying
to women all the time. I talk about all of this. But I'm the
hero in this story. I'm the hero, guys. I am the hero and I'll
protect you all from the women. That girl sent LWD selfies to
people while she was married and talked about her shave snatch.
She also spread rumors about Paul Watson while she was married
at Ry Liberty. Your client is a bro. Please put the theosaurus
down. That's a good one. Yeah, bro. You are not in Lord of the
Rings. You are not Tolken. Okay. I am not inspired. Just shut
the up. All right.
Absolutely
cringe. God.
All right. So, from there, I believe we have Where do I have
my Tommy Robinson tweet? He quote tweeted this. Tommy Robinson
quote tweeted this and he put out his he basically echoed his
previous statement. Okay. Sorry, it bollocks. So, this is going
to be very similar to the statement we watched yesterday on on
the whole thing. So, he was there in Romania when Lauren Southern
and Andrew Tate had this encounter. Uh, he says that Lauren was
kissing him on the way to the room. I haven't heard Lauren address
this directly, right? I think she said, well, sorry, she's she's
not addressed this claim directly. I believe she said Tommy was
lying about everything, right? Lied about her to discredit her.
So, I assume she has she has said that this is not true.
And but the way she said it and she focused on like the car after.
So I don't know. But I think there are cases where and like I'm
not saying this happened here, but I would say there probably
are cases where it takes some thinking about an encounter to
realize like oh something really up happened. I believe Tommy.
Uh people can believe Tommy if they want. Didn't Lauren admit
in the article to kissing him in his bed anyways? Yeah. But that's
an entirely different thing, right? Hayoka archetype. So she
admitted to kissing him before they had before she was raped.
Kissing him after the just seems very bizarre. It's hard for
most people to know what's going on there, right? Never said
she wasn't showing interest, did she? She just explicitly fought
against having and said no before the choking. Yeah, like technically,
yeah, that's a good point, Magic Dragon. Technically, she could
have been and still been doing that. I don't know. Like, to me,
that also feels weird, but it it really does depend on the evidence
and what she told people about the encounter. Yes, I think so.
Why wouldn't you? Like, really?
Okay. Or was the implied consent? Oh, yeah. Okay. Let's listen
to this. Here's a horrible fact. Okay, I was there when Romania
with Andrew Tape. I was in the hotel room next door. When I walked
out in the morning when we were leaving, Lauren Suffins at the
door kissing. >> Okay. So, when you read what she says
there, like she's implying.
It's a bit weird to be kissing him on his door and then get in
the car and message him the whole way. Insanity. >> So,
that would be weird. That would be weird. I don't know. I don't
know if this is true, but that would be weird. I'd agree. That's
like weird to me. But if she went to the cops, if she contacted
the police and contacted like a medical clinic to say this is
what happened, then I guess you would probably what I would want
to see is the text they exchanged right after, right? The text
they exchanged right after and the report from the medical facility
and how it lined up, right? So I could see a world I I could
you have to you have to allow for this or you're not really being
honest where like she was texting him and then they broke off
contact and she goes to the the guy after the doctor after to
say this is what happened, right? And then Ken and and the other
guy in the car don't really corroborate what happened,
right? That it's possible that Lauren could have done something
malicious here. It's possible. But I I the the two people the
character the people on on Andrew Tate's side, it's Tommy Robinson
and Andrew Tate. They're both like known scammers, liars, total
scum, right? Lauren Southern been scum at different points, but
I don't see why she would. I don't know, man. You got to see
texts and stuff, too. You'd have to see a lot of evidence. I
just feel like I would probably at a base level be pretty understanding,
pretty pretty close to believing Southern. But I have a lot of
people who messaged me and they're like, "You don't understand
that Lauren Southern total total. She up big time." Okay. She
everybody. And I'm like, "Dude, I don't know if you know this,
but I think like probably get uh more than like chased women."
Almost certainly that's just that's just true. Okay. You're way
more likely to get raped if you're a if you're like constantly
in situations.
>> Yeah, exactly. Selling a sloth. I don't think that's
very likely to be true because I would think that if that were
true, if that were how it went, then people could be posting
logs on the other side, right? To say like, well, actually, a
week later is when I broke it off and I'll let me just post these
logs. Andrew Tate said he's going to post logs, so we'll see
if he does.
anyway, anyway, we've got way more on this. I'm gonna do a couple
segments on this as well. So, I've got the Tim Pool segment that
I'd love to listen to. >> Lauren Southern has mostly because
I think there's been like a theory that >> returned from
>> that like Lauren Southern probably had or sorry, Tim
might have had a thing for Lauren Southern. He I believe he funded
her Borderless documentary, right? So, I believe he funded Borderless.
I think he had a bit of a thing for her likely, right? when he's
talked about the woman, his ideal woman. I think he's kind of
talked about Lauren in some cases.
And it's, by the way, that's like we're kind of we don't know
that for sure. Is Timmy Pool going to dumpster? He might have
to. Okay. He can't he can't say I support Lauren Southern and
I'm I'm going to take this Trump Epstein thing lying down. He
can't do both of those in the same week, right? That would be
really bad for him. So, I think he could only choose one and
he's probably Listen, he's got to pick one person who he'd rather
get by. It's almost certainly Donald Trump and not Lauren Southern.
Okay. Unlucky. But I think another guy I believe another guy
from Tim's show actually had a relationship with Lauren. I'm
trying to remember this for sure cuz this is one of those things
where I've heard this that Lauren was with somebody else in the
show and that's why but I think I think the person I was talking
to cuz I I clarified. I think the person I was talking to about
that was confused and didn't realize it was D Lagouna and not
Southern because I know De Lagona had a relationship with somebody
who was on Tim Pool's show and it's another Lauren and they might
have heard something secondhand. So I yeah there's there's like
some things going on there. Anyway, none of that really matters.
I think Tim did have a thing for her, but I I assume that that
kept going and maybe it didn't. Maybe now that Borderless is
came out and stuff. We'll see. Just watch. Nothing is shameless
enough for Timmy Pool. Okay, we have the Tim Pool thing. of the
quartering segment which I'm also going to watch. It's just 15
>> apparently. Lauren Southern >> get the hate watch
on the quartering a little bit and then we've got some other
>> So I'll go I'll go back and forth. We'll we'll hate
watch a little bit of Tim Pool. We'll hate watch a little bit
of the quartering response and then what do we do after that?
Okay, we'll go from that to a couple more tweets. We'll we'll
get some more negative tweets because the right-wingers are very
very upset about this. Okay, they're very upset. They do not
believe Lauren Southern at all. They think Lawrence. But again,
what I want to see is what I want to see from all of these people.
I should actually highlight it is I want to see them actually
be critical of I want to see them be critical of
the things Lauren says. Say you don't have proof for this, you
don't have proof for that. You don't like you say you're a drug.
That's weird to make it. I want to see them go after that. I
don't want to see them just saying this girl's a you don't understand.
She a lot of people. This girl's a This girl's a I don't think
that's like I don't think that's, you know, showing me that you
really know what you're talking about or that you have any honest
engagement with this. I think it's just goofy. Okay, so we'll
see. We'll see how it goes. >> Is back for the four >> Oh,
no, no, no. Not you. I want to do Timmy Pool first. Retirement
with a new book. Lawrence Southern has returned from retirement
with a new book called This Is Not Real Life, for which she has
released a few select chapters to give you a sneak preview of
what the book may be about. And of course, that sneak preview
is the accusation that Andrew Tate had her at a hotel in Romania.
The Rolling St. I will say the start of this does not sound favorable
for her. I'm getting a drink. I'm getting water. I'm use the
bathroom real quick. So, I'm going to let this I'm going to let
him roll through the factual parts of the story really quickly
because he'll actually give us introduction. If you weren't here
yesterday, you didn't watch any of this stuff. You'll get some
introduction to the topic. And it'll give me like a minute and
a half, two minutes to be right back. >> Jones running
the story. Alt-right YouTuber Lauren Southern alleges in memoir
that Andrew Tate assaulted her. Now, uh let me start by saying
this. Uh
full disclosure,
I consider myself friends with Lauren Southern. In fact, I I
consider her to be like a decently good friend, though I haven't
seen her in years. She retired from the scene. We do have uh
she has been in the show several times. She has famously drink
a drunken whiskey, Papy as it were, from a paper cup, not realizing
that is inappropriate. You can't do that. And so, uh I've got
my opinions on this and it's it's tough. This one really is.
I've got uh knowing her personally,
uh being friends with having many of the same friends, having
been at many of the same news locations as her and even covered
similar stories on trips with her in the past, though, uh just
a couple. I have my opinions on this
as well as many of the individuals I I still work with and know.
And the general sentiment is
ain't no way this story is true. Ain't no way. Now, I'm not sitting
here to try and uh
defend Andrew Tate over anything he may have done. I can certainly
give the man credit for his strong rhetoric, which inspires young
men. The left can deny it all they want. They can tell me, they
can insult me because they don't like that I said it, but it's
true. Clearly, the dude has 10 million followers on X and is
extremely wealthy. Something he's saying is resonating whether
you like it or not. Now, as to the claim that he had assaulted
Lauren Southern, even I
I'm skeptical of this story. I am. And it is tough again because
I want to believe that uh my friend is going to write something
that is honest and truthfully depicts what happened. >> But
it's Timmy Timmyy's not taking her side, guys.
Oh boy. Timmy is not He's not going to take her side. Not good.
Not good. He can't, Dude. He cannot do He cannot be on Trump's
side on the Epcene thing, which I He's made a little noise about
it, but on Twitter, there's been a couple other things. He's
He's desperately trying to get out of that one. Okay. He can't
still like Trump and and take Lauren side. He He'd be selling
himself down the river. Hard to believe even with someone like
Andrew Tate. So, let's read this story and break down what's
going on. Now, I will add
that um Lauren Southern is saying she won't do press on this.
other individuals that she's communic with also are saying they're
not going to talk about it. So she put out these chapters, made
the accusation, and then that's the end of it. Buy the book if
you'd like. But the general sentiment right now, not among the
immediate close circle, like again, like I know a lot of people
who are friends with Lauren. I consider myself a friend of Lauren.
The the outside of that, sorry I have this muted. I have this
muted. She talked to one mainstream journalist on the left. Somebody
asked if she talked to journalists. So, um, she talked to one
mainstream journalist on the left and then she talked to
Sean Ultra, uh, what is his name? Actual justice warrior, right?
She talked to him. So, there are two journalists who are involved
and have seen more evidence. Not everybody's seen all the evidence.
So, a lot of other people want to. Huh? Wait, wait, wait. Including
Willie Mack. She said, "I will not be taking interviews on this."
And under that tweet, Willie Mack literally replies, "Do you
think this is more evidence that he can't read, by the way? No,
I won't be doing interviews. Don't ask. DMs, please. I have some
questions.
He l Willie Slackjaw cannot read.
He cannot read. He like right clicks things and he gets it to
like do text to speech for him. And if he if he gets bored and
stops, he actually can't read. He can't just parse this information
himself. Amazing. Amazing. I will No, I will not be doing interviews.
Don't ask. Dams, please. I have some questions.
Oh, good times. Good times. >> The answer is she's just
selling a book now. Uh I don't mean to impugn the honor of Lauren,
but I'm just going to read through the story, let you know that
uh there's there's like this this is this is a subjective case.
I know this person, and I'll give you my thoughts on the matter.
Rolling Stone says, "Altright YouTuber Lauren Southern alleges
in memoir that Andrew Tate assaulted her." I I want to stress
Lauren is not alt-right.
That's just so cringe. Lauren has never been alt-right. She's
always actually been fairly moderate. Right. >> Okay. So,
he starts us off with possibly the worst analysis I've ever seen
in my life. Lauren Southern, the person who talked about like
French braids not being was it France not being France anymore
and like how there are no French braids in Paris. This person
who literally joined the like rap what was it? What would you
call it? like a a white identity group in Europe tried to prevent
migrants from entering the country. That girl wasn't alt-right.
That's moderate right. What the is alt-right now? There's pro
there's some small possibility here that what Tim means is she's
not outright anti-semitic and that is a calling card of the alt-right.
Right. She was never moderate right though. That's insane. Generation
identity. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. She's never
been moderate right. That's insane. That's an insane thing to
say, right? just hang in a room with Stephan Molyneu. Yeah. Like,
dude, there's nobody there's nobody near her who is like an early
career collaborator who's not alt-right or like super farright.
Anyway, >> um and alt-right is defined by the AP style
guide as white nationalist.
So, >> and it would be totally inappropriate to call Lauren
Southern
at any point in her career white nationalist apparently. Come
on, dude. Come on, Timmy. Come on, Timmy. Does he feel like sweeping
here makes up for him going like she's probably lying about Andrew
Tate? Is that what he thinks? Like I'll sweep for her on the
white identity front, but you know, on this allegations, no,
no, no. Andrew Tate's probably innocent. >> Certainly.
Uh Lauren, there there like I don't know how you even describe
it. Probably a similar space to most of us. We recognize that
there is a tie between certain races and cultures due to the
historical growth trends of those periods and those countries.
But Lauren is not someone who's ever advocated for a a the United
States to get rid of uh brown people and become a white nation
or anything like that or to have a white nationalist homeland
or anything.
>> Okay. Isn't Lauren the person? Dude, I think this is
like insane cope. This is like Would you not call Tommy Robinson
a white nationalist? Who did she fly? Who is she trying to make
a new
that Wick's new co-host is a race realist? Nope. That's cool
though. That's pretty funny. She just wants to stop being replaced.
Yeah, dude. She's literally went on a podcast arguing that the
UK should do exactly that like a year ago. Yeah, I don't know.
This is some crazy cope. I've just never seen this level of cope.
This is absolutely wild. She literally joined a white identity
group in Europe that was trying to keep browns out. What like
that? Certainly, there's an argument about Europe and indigenous
that certain white identitarian groups have made. But I digress.
Rolling Stone says Lauren Southern, the Canadian YouTuber who
was once a rising star on the far right thanks to her hardline
anti-immigrant anti-feminist views, but later retreated from
the scene, has alleged in her new self-published memoir, this
is not real life, that she was assaulted by embattled misogynist
influencer Andrew Tate in 2018 when she was 2022.
That's I I don't understand the
Oh, Tim's doing the thing again where he didn't read any of this
stuff at all and he's going to form an opinion based on headlines
and tweets. Tim often does this. He will not actually look at
the relevant material. He will just look at like the conversation
on Twitter and be like, "Okay, if I wanted to like basically
I'm just going to take a dash of this person's opinion, a dash
of that person's opinion, and then okay, this is clearly lying.
This is lying. She didn't get timeline doesn't make sense. Wait,
you know that like nobody disputes that she was in a hotel room
with Andrew Tate at the exact time. Literally, Andrew Tate says
he at that exact time. What the do you mean? The timeline doesn't
make sense. Are you out of your mind, Tim? Are you out of your
mind? What is wrong with this? What is wrong with this person
hanging out with Lauren around the same time? Anyway,
no, he did not just Oh god, this just got sad.
Oh god. He didn't just say what he just said, did he? >> Stay
the timeline.
I was hanging out with Lauren around the same time. No.
No. No.
Dude, you hear that, right? You I can't be the only one who hears
it. Dude, the timeline here doesn't even make sense. I was I
was hanging out with Lauren around the same time. Around the
same time. Brother thought he had a shot. Brother thought he
was competing with Andrew Tate. brother thought he had a shot
at. Okay, I I can't be the only one who hears that, right? >> 2018
when she was 2022. >> She was 2022. 2022. Yeah. I I don't
understand the timeline.
I was hanging out with Lauren around the same time. Anyway, the
accusation detailed in excerpts southern her Substack page. >> She
definitely she definitely wasn't sleeping with anyone else. She
wasn't going out with other guys at that time. She wasn't doing
that. Come on. >> Adds to an already lengthy list of allegations,
etc. In the chapters published on our substack, Southern describes
traveling from the UK with British Islamophobic activist Tommy
Robinson to Romania around February 2018. What was I doing in
February 2018 to meet with the Tates and their team about a supposed
The best part about that is the fact that like Tommy, Laura,
literally Andrew, everybody backed up the timeline. The timeline
is totally correct to all of them. opport
he he picked the only part of this story that is not subjective
or up for debate in any way and just said I'm pretty skeptical
of that >> to launch a new right-wing media venture with
the siblings investment nervous of the lack of preparation for
a pitch and because she alleges Robinson was >> no no no
it gets way better than that he didn't she didn't just say she
wasn't interested
um she probably said something like oh no I'm really focused
on my career and I don't think I'd like mess up my career by
sleeping with anybody who's in media and then she went to like
a funding meeting and slept with somebody who was in media.
That's almost certainly that's almost certainly how it >> Impaired
by that he managed to smuggle aboard the plane. I I'm sorry.
I just don't believe it. Look, man, uh I've not talked to Lauren
about this. I'm just going to say outright
in her writing where she mentions that he was doing K over and
over again. The only actual thing I can discern from what she
wrote is that Tommy went to the bathroom a couple of times. Now,
by all means, maybe she like she's not >> Hold on.
Why? I I spit on that opinion. Okay. Why are you What do you
think he was doing, dude? Nobody Nobody is going to deny that
either. I don't even know, dude. Tommy Robinson hasn't come out
and gone, she said I did coke. I don't do coke. I >> I'm
not saying she's I don't know. I'm saying I personally don't
find the sufficient evidence to claim that Tommy Robinson was
coked out of his mind. I I've met the guy. Not that I've met
I met I think I met Tommy one time. I've covered a bit of his
story. Uh again, I have mutual friends and people that I work
with who know Tommy and they're like the general sentiment is
like BS.
Like to write a >> I don't believe that. I have not seen
a single person who looked at this story so far and went guys
the idea that Tommy Robinson is a drug addict or does does coke
or something. That's insane.
Nobody's saying that story and say Tommy went to the bathroom
many times because he was doing coke. It's well he went to the
bathroom many times but maybe he just ate too much Taco Bell.
Okay. I don't know.
Uh Tommy Robinson, former EDL leader, jailed for fraud, 2014.
Fake pay slips. Also in the dock was Steven Voss. This person.
Oh, hold on. No, no, no, no, no. You didn't. You didn't look
through this correctly. Space Ghost. No, this is somebody else
with Coke. He also admitted this is Steven Voss.
Hold on, hold on.
>> Who is this? Why is this person near him? So the do
is this person conspiring with others to obtain a mortgage by
misrepresentation. This is someone else. I'm pretty sure. I know,
but it's shady. Okay. Well, listen. I think >> Oh, I just
I just I just um Sorry, the the link wasn't good, but I just
find it insane that like Tommy Robinson didn't even come out
and go like, "I don't do coke, guys. I don't do coke. I don't
do guys. I don't do coke at all." >> A bit of a story.
Uh, again, I have mutual friends and people that I work with
who know Tommy and they're like the general sentiment is like
BS.
Like to write a story and say Tommy went to the bathroom many
times cuz he was doing Coke. It's like I know. Well, he went
to the bathroom many times, but maybe he just ate too much Taco
Bell. Okay, I don't know. I wasn't there. I just find that hard
to believe.
Um, he smuggled Coke on a commercial aircraft. Like, I I don't
believe. Come on. That's crazy.
So, >> oh, I see. So, people have accused Tommy of using
donations to his stuff to buy, and I'm guessing Tim's defended
him on that. So, in 2021, there was an allegation that he misused
donations to pay for Coke. If this would load,
but that'll be what this is about. I'm guessing claim former
allies.
>> So, yeah. Apparently a bunch of people are accusing
him of doing Coke and spending his donations instead of on political
activism on Coke explicitly.
>> So that was being surprised by the tates whom she >> why
it's important to >> when they turned up at the airport
in Bucharest. Two sharply dressed men leaned against polished
sports cars, she writes, saying they stood out like sore thumbs
against a washed out Balkan backdrop. Andrew drove something
to a dinner for just the two of them in a steakhouse, she claims,
and was excessively complimentary of her work. Flirtatious and
somewhat char >> Oh, wait. Hold on. Are you sure? Are you
sure about that, Ally? Cuz I just looked at another thing and
it was somebody else it seemed like had had the possession of
Coke. Somebody, if you guys want to look at that in the >> she
notes that they really did get along during these conversations,
though eventually she adds, >> "Also, what's up? >> Feel
off later." >> Said, "It would be surprising if Tommy Robinson
never did coke is a big part of UK publish culture." >> Feel
off. Later, she, Robinson, and their video team were taken to
the Tate's compound, which other describes as a building that
looked like it had been designed by edgy Reddit mods and anime
nerds turned Mary Condo minimalist fanatics with an imposing
samurai statue for decoration and a small army of crypto bros.
>> I'm going to speed up his reading. >> Seemed like
the brothers were the muscle and drivers. Well, the crypto guys
were the ones doing the actual work. She writes, "She basically
goes on to say that instead of talking about a strong investment,
they made propitions on a crypto token, the Freedom Coin or something
like this, that freedom token that they could promote through
the Avenger, which would generate lots of money and and things
like that." and they were she was concerned that wasn't actually
a real business meeting. She says uh basically with a group of
return to the hotel convinced they blow it. They takes a message
they want to talk more southern she compound where she plays
Andrew photo with her and pose with his hand wrapped around her
waist wa wa wa wa wa wa wa wa wa like we've been dating for years.
She said I mean I just come on like Andrew takes a get a photo
of his arm around you. This is why K Reeves did the hand floating
thing. Do you guys remember the story where K Reeves like wouldn't
she's not she's not saying anything bad here? She's saying he's
comfortable with women. He's like a womanizer. She's not saying
she's assaulted here. She was like oh I wasn't used to this but
hey this is what happened. Also, not even sure that this is true,
but >> touch women. >> Like, sorry, I'm not even
sure. Like, it's possible she was very used to men putting their
hands around her. It doesn't really matter. It's like, it's like
just a detail in the story. Why is Tim focusing on this? >> But
I digress. I digress. Again, she says that she told him she didn't
want to go out unless Tommy and her other producers were there.
But, >> in 2018, he was a nobody. He's a kickboxing world
champion who's also like a multi-millionaire living in Romania.
He obviously would have had women around him. He's already running
his cam business, too. and to assure them they would be. She
says they went to a they went to a a nightclub.
She had a a shot of liquor before feeling nauseatingly drunk
and having someone carry her to a bathroom, which I feel like
the obvious insinuation is that she was drugged. >> Uh
she vomited at some point after she claims Andrew carried her
to a car, drove her back to >> obviously insinuated. >> There
alleges state asked to sleep beside her on the bed to which she
agreed while incredibly intoxicated. Once again, here's the challenge.
Claiming that like I agreed while I was so drunk is a very feminist
thing to do. Yes, I was. Okay. What? I don't Why would that be
a fe I think probably the feminist thing to do would would be
to say I was incapable of consenting. >> So inebriated
that I invited him to sleep in my bed. He kissed me. I wasn't
expecting it. I was looking for it, but I kissed him back briefly
and told him I wanted to sleep. I was extraordinarily tired.
He he wanted to go further. I said no very clearly multiple times
and tried to pull his hands off me. He also, just for clarity,
he misstated what happened. Tate asked to sleep beside him on
asked her to sleep beside him on the bed to which she agreed.
She didn't invite but it's not a big deal. Not not a huge not
a huge strangle.
I tried to fight back. He repeatedly strangled me every time
I regain enough consciousness to pull his arms. I prefer not
to share the rest. It's pretty obvious. It It's not actually.
It's not. >> She got He choked her out and then her unconscious
body. You idiot. Yes. He penetrated her vaginally
at minimum. That is what is implied when she says, "I'd rather
not say the rest, idiot." Is Tim actually a virgin? No, it's
not clear what happened to me. Wait, she You choked. You got
choked out and he was on top of you and then I don't Then you
say you'd rather not discuss the Well, I don't know what happened
there. What could have possibly happened there? I have no idea
what happened there. Not obvious.
The is >> It's obvious to literally everybody else. Is
the art like was it that they had a rough make out? Like look
what what is he doing? Why?
>> Why? What in a rough make out? What? Yeah, he choked
her he choked her out to make out with her, Tim. Yep. Yep. Yep.
This guy is like an alien. This guy is like not actually a human
male. He does not I don't know what we're doing here. I don't
know what's happening. >> With all due respect, when I
read this, it's like it's not pretty obvious. I understand the
insinuation, sure, but we don't actually have any accusation.
We know what the insinuation is, but Lauren has not said explicitly
that's what happened. This wasn't a case of mixed signals or
intoxicated blurred lines. I fought back. I was pleading. I just
didn't realize there was a point of no return. A moment where
my voice would no longer have any power by leaving all of that
out of it. She >> What do you think she was doing while
she fought back and was pleading, Tim? What was she pleading
with him not to >> She's effectively indemnifying herself
from defamation. >> No, she's not. No, she's not. No, she's
not.
Defamation. I believe it's what a reasonable person would expect.
Is there a single reasonable person in the world who goes she's
not claiming she was raped here? No, it's obvious. I don't I
understand there's like a little bit of leeway there or something,
right? But it's like I don't think there's a single person who
go on a jury in the world and say this isn't a allegation. It's
not it's not uh what do you call it? Just being like incredibly
obvious but not saying the words exactly. It's not like, oh,
she said she was and now now it's a allegation. It's just going
to be what a reasonable person how a reasonable person would
interpret this, right? Does she not even say? I don't know if
she says or not. I actually don't remember if she said the word
or not, but it is incredibly incredibly obvious when she says
that other victims of his who are suing him for assault or something
had incredibly consistent patterns and they were raped. Right.
Hey, they were raped. I have the same pattern as as another woman
who accused them of rape. We have the same case. I'd like to
help her with her case. >> If Andrew Tate says she insinuated,
well, to be fair, that's not necessarily correct. But if he says
she accused me of, she can say I absolutely did not. I say he
was being rough with me in bed as we kissed. And that's kind
of the argument though. Dude, this guy is brain broken. This
is Dude,
how do I I feel like I turn this guy on, I don't pre-watch his
stuff at all, and every single time I turn him on, he is making
the worst the dumbest arguments I've ever heard in my entire
life. Oh, what was the Apple thing that he did? That Apple doesn't
innovate. Apple hasn't innovated in like 20 years. Apple's not
contributed anything to the world of technology in like 20 years
or something is what he said. He said something like this and
it's like, "Brother,
the iPhone, like the iPhone, there's there's a bunch of other
stuff. Okay. Apple silicone chips. Like there's a whole bunch
of things. Silicon silicon.
Who do you hate worse? Him or Destiny?" For political analysis,
him by a mile. Obviously, his political analysis is completely
brain like brain damaged.
Completely brain damaged. Uh I don't know. I haven't seen him,
you know, violating people's consent repeatedly as a pattern,
but if he did, he could be worse. Oh, probably wouldn't fly because
everybody understands the insinuation is. Years later, she would
read a vice news report about how Tate had been arrested on suspicion
over in the UK in 2015 with one alleged victim telling the outlet
that Tate had strangled her on multiple occasions. In the aftermath
of the of the assault, Southern explained she tried to minimize
the incident in part because she felt that her anti-feminist
brand precluded her from coming forward as a victim. I wouldn't
have believed another one who made these exact set of claims.
I got to be honest, most people still don't. Tommy Robinson has
come out uh he posted a video refuting this outright. Andrew
Tate has issued a statement saying it's absolutely not true.
No, he didn't refute this outright. He said, "I saw them kiss
the morning after." And why would she kiss him if uh why would
she kiss him if she got raped? Which is to me I'm like, okay,
that would be weird, right? That that cast out on the story.
I'm not going to say it does nothing. Okay, that does cast out
in the story. But Tommy Robinson is an infamous liar. He was
around Andrew Tate a lot after this, right? He had a business
connection with Andrew Tate. He is incentivized to protect Andrew
Tate's reputation 100%. Uh beyond that, okay, I think Tommy also
said that she flew back to Romania. I would assume that that's
something she can just totally disprove, right? He was like,
I I believe she flew back to Romania to meet him again. And Tate
hasn't claimed that, by the way. So, I guess we'll see. We'll
see if more evidence gets posted for it or whatever. I I feel
like all of this I'm just I'm just enjoying the cope that people
are putting out, right? Where they can't really they can't mount
any coherent defense of the things she's saying against the things
she's saying. So they mostly just say insane things like well
she's a so what what are we supposed to do? Why do you believe
this? Why do you believe this mentally ill? It's like the same
refrain we've heard a lot recently bizarrely.
Yeah. We just keep hearing the same refrain saying this is what
women do. They'll take consensual acts and then claim retroactively
that it was assault. Tommy Robinson said the very next morning
because he was in the hotel right beside her. She was kissing
him as they were leaving. Not something you'd think would be
happening with someone who was just insulted or take your for
what it is. The following year, Southern announced her retirement
from activism, indicating she wanted to return her attention
to academia and personal relationships. Then far-right troll
Mileopoulos published a piece smearing her, asserting that Southern
had been a secret leftist all along and manipulated unnamed men
in order to advance her career as a political commentator. Southern
claims she soon got soon got word that tape was telling his private
online networks that he was one of the sources for Yiannopoulos's
piece and joking they had never had any intention of funding
the media project she and Robinson had tried to pitch in Bucharest.
writing a group chat message. Do pimps give girls money? Yes,
they do. What? Tate, they do. Like, what are you talking about?
>> Okay, I don't get it. Like, >> do you see the
tweet from yesterday about the Epstein files? Is that the one
where he said that uh now Democrats are trying to get the US
government to publish child? Yeah, we saw that. We covered that.
That was stupid. Obviously, he's embarrassing. He's incredibly
embarrassing. This is
Yeah, absolutely insane. That dude
Yeah. This is This is who Tim is now. He just tweets humiliating
things. Slowly grinds his audience away take by take by take.
So when is J going to invite LS on with her own custom PNG?
>> Uh probably never. I don't know how you would I don't
reach out to these people ever. I never reach out to somebody
I'm >> Yes, they buy them. >> Weird when you have
allegations like this. It just be weird to reach out to them.
Obviously >> they take a lot of the money. Southern claims
she later realized that Tate had messaged her on social media
a year before they had been introduced. And she had casually
corresponded with him like any other fan, but she hadn't connected
the dots when they came face to face. She was left wondering
if Robinson was in on a setup to make her available to take was
I trafficked. WTF? Oh, please,
dude. Come on. This is brutal. And uh Oh, man. I don't know.
I'm not going to pretend like I was like great friends with Lauren
Southern and we hung out all the time. I want to hear more. How
much did you give her for her documentary, >> But we did
hang out. I did consider us to be friends, you know. I don't
know. This just like seems kind of nuts to be honest. And don't
get me wrong, there are some dirty, deceious people behind the
scenes. So, there's probably, but come on. The idea that Tommy
trafficked Lauren to Tate, you know what I mean? She concludes,
"I don't hate Andrew." She expressed the belief that she might
yet change as a person. I hope he becomes the soul he could have
been instead of the one consumed by his vices. Whether behind
bars or free, but I don't think he even realized he's been consumed
like somebody in his position, he's likely never let himself
dig that deep because there's too much pain waiting there. Well,
I'll let you guys in a secret. agitated reached out to me I think
in like 2016 or so he's prominent on X not very many followers
to be honest but like tens of thousands and he had hit me up
about uh some kind of media venture unrelated to anything it
was just like let's go place let's go on the ground I can't remember
exactly what it was fairly innocuous that's why I'm like >> for
a collaboration >> that's crazy within like a year or two
years of him having like 40k followers he's got hundreds of thousands
maybe millions and he was super wealthy and successful now southern
accus him him of crypto pump and dump schemes which >> oh
guys I I didn't even see where like 3 hours into the stream already.
Guys, if you like the content, go ahead and follow me on all
platforms. x.com/jdlk
with an un twitch.tv/jstlk
with an underscore kick. I mean, you're probably following on
kick if you're listening to this. Uh, join the Discord.
If you want to take your support one step further, I really appreciate
any amount of money you can give to help support the stream,
help support me, help support me against the prospect of future
homelessness. Okay? You can sub on kick, you can give subs on
kick, you can sub on Twitch, you throw me to Twitch Prime, twitch.tv/jsdlk
TV/JSLK with an underscore if you want to do that. All right.
Um, I love individual subs on Kick. If you do not have a sub
and you can individually sub, I really appreciate those cuz it
gives me a nice rolling income on Kick that I can depend on every
single month. Uh, if you don't want to donate through Kick, you
can go through the TTS sites. There's Kickbot. There's Streamlabs.
Kickbot $3, sorry, $2 minimum on Kickbot. Whoops, I'm replying
to that, not pinning it. It's a $2 minimum on Kickbot, $3 minimum
on Streamlabs. Every dollar you donate through these methods
goes to more time on the stream. We are currently about 11 subs
away. 11 subs away from two more hours on the stream. All right,
so you could donate, you could sub. Uh, last but not least, this
does not go towards time on the stream, but there's the Patreon
as well. patreon.com/jok.
patreon.com/jok.
Multiple roles. It's mostly for perks in the Discord. Okay. Talking
through the first hour in the stream. Uh, what else is there?
There's talking through the first hour. There's, I think, soundboards
in the VCs. Pre-stream postream content at the Yolo tier. Guys,
sign up for the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
I appreciate any dollar you can go you can give. Okay, thank
you very much. Ask a kick mod why you can't individually sub
on the iOS uh iOS app. I don't Yeah, I don't know about that.
Uh that sucks if you can't, but I appreciate anything you guys
give. Okay, always appreciate it. Love more time on the stream.
Love all of the support we get. So, thank you guys very much.
Going to continue on with the show.
>> Listen, you know, here's the post she made. I'm gonna
say this. A lot of this is written with the context of hindsight.
That is, it's easy to line up stories and say Tommy Robinson
was doing No, hold on. She wrote that he was going to the bathroom
a lot. Like, did she witness him doing the bathroom? No, she
wasn't in the bathroom. So, what can I say about that accusation?
Based on who I know and the people that know Tommy, it flies
in the face of who he is that he's some out dude smuggling drugs
on commercial airplanes. I mean, that's movieesque. Who tried
>> I I think like this is probably not really relevant.
This is like absolutely not relevant to anything. She's putting
it in for flavor, but I'm not sure that she meant that as like
an allegation. Sorry. The Tommy stuff to me ring reads more like
just a like basically relevant context for the story, but not
really an allegation at all. Like not really something she cares
about. It's just like everybody around him knew he was doing
Coke all the time. She l later literally said later that Tommy
invited her to do Coke and she turned him down. She did say that.
I smuggle in a commercial airplane. You could you get locked
up forever for that. And then stuff about Andrew Tate. I'd flip
a coin on it to be honest. certainly got a lot of accusations,
but a lot of them we do know that they were not true. I'm not
going to pretend he's a good guy. He was doing the weird creepy
Only fan stuff. But it's easy after the news already broken to
write something like this that aligns with the current traditional
view. I will add the inverse.
It aligns with the view possibly because that's who these people
always have been. I don't know. But I'm going to let you in on
how I feel ultimately. Lauren's publishing a book right now.
Okay? It's available on Amazon. This is not real life. I I'm
sorry. I wish he I wish he'd said like I know people who accuse
me of this and while I am trying to make money with this book.
Uh I'm not actually that focused on making money from the Tate
allegations. So I'm publishing this. If you think it's a marketing
ploy, I understand you see it that way. It kind of is that. But
I I wanted to make sure that I could publish this for free so
that people didn't have to pay just to see the allegation. So
here it is. If you want to say that it's fine. I don't like the
whole like I don't I just don't like it doesn't feel good when
people do the um it doesn't feel good. It's just not I maybe
like smart optically, right, to do the oh well, I'm not really
trying to to profit from this. It's like, yeah, you are, and
that's okay. As long as you're telling the truth, that's fine.
>> To put out a book releasing a free chapter where you
claim a high-profile guy with 10 million followers you doesn't
sound honest. >> How does Tim How does Tim like square
this with the fact that there have been rumors of this allegation
going back to 2019 and 2020,
right? that like other people had made this allegation unofficially
and Lauren had said I don't want to talk about it going back
to like 2019 2020 like it's not that this allegation is coming
to light with the book I've talked about this allegation on my
stream before more than once I believe that Lauren Southern was
insulted or by Andrew Tate as like people have literally have
literally talked about this her camera guy talked about it Tommy
admitting to sniffing coke in his past >> at that period
that's gone you sniffing as well I was yeah I was Um I watch
if I go on a bender. Um >> you have another pipe. >> Nah.
Never. I'll never touch anything like that. No. No. >> Okay.
Well, yeah. Sniff. Okay. Okay. >> The only look >> Look
at this Egene Carol thing. Eene Carol accuses Trump of assault
in her memoir, her forthcoming book. So these women are like,
I'm going to publish a book and I'm going to market my Okay.
You're sure? Listen, man. I don't know. I didn't reach out to
Lauren about this. Um, I'm sure >> she'll tell me this
is all completely true. We've uh in in the past, obviously, like
she's been a 10 cast hour, we've reached out to her about, you
know, being on the show and being involved, but she's very much
saying she's completely retired. My my honest assessment of Lauren
is that um she got dra she got into all of this stuff because
she like called out feminism and then I think someone like splashed
urine or milk her. She got a lot of attention. She was a young
attractive female so she was able to build a quick following
and then she pursued this political line as it generated attention
and revenue. But she got to the point where she was at odds with
international governments, which she writes in her summary of
her >> To the point where she was being threatened by our
government, her government, even the UK had banned her. I think
Australia had banned her. And >> and this is it's got to
be scary to be going up against global powers who are saying,
"You've crossed the line. You've become persona." To which she
decides to basically retire. >> Maybe she realized she
never really cared all that much and this life was damaging to
her. >> I certainly have questions. um in the pursuit of
my passions in the cultural news and political spaces, there
are threats to my life and my family. And I've said this before
and I'll and I'll say it now. Maybe it's different. Maybe I'm
a guy, so it's different, right? When I was living in Jersey
and only had this channel and the Timcast channel, I was making
millions of dollars with zero staff. Millions. It was like the
first couple of years, I remember it was like 2018, maybe the
first year that I actually made my first million dollars or something.
I'm not trying to brag, okay, guys? Some people just they hear
this and they're like, "Oh, I'm just explaining that at that
time with the success that I was having, I was wrapping up work.
I would work from about 7 a.m. until 4 p.m. every day." >> I
don't know what point is he making. Like, what is the point of
this? >> And I had the rest of the night to play World
of Warcraft. I was playing World of Warcraft. I was watching
movies. I was going to movie theaters. I was going to dinner,
hanging out. I had time and I had a lot of money, more than any
single person would uh would want or not necessarily, but need.
And then co happened and I decided to launch Timcast IRL which
has now doubled my more than doubled my workload and actually
cost more money in the long run. It's resulted in a strong amount
of cultural influence certainly but I don't from zero to three.
How many rough make outs do you think Tim has been a part of?
Uh
I mean I'm going to say three because of the meme but dude I
I don't know what this rough make out garbage is dude. >> Dude.
Yeah. I I think the answer has to be zero in actuality because
he does it because he came up with the theory. But yeah, as a
meme three, but really zero. I'm sorry. Zero that I've ever had
what it takes to be more than what we're doing here, right? I
would need to buy property and live in DC proper. But I kind
of just do what I want to do. The point I'm making is not to
make it about myself. I don't know. Whatever. Maybe I am. The
point I'm making is that I think there are how I'm I'm kind of
personalizing Lauren's story. When I encounter the threats from
government, the smears, the sc campaigns, the false accusations,
the death threats, the swatting attacks,
I genuinely reflect on, is this worth it to go to war with the
powers that be? When they have told you, we will let you be rich,
just shut your mouth. And then I'm like, no, I'm going to I'm
going to drive my passions. And then it becomes a burden. It
becomes difficult. And even I've had my struggles where you've
seen me talk about it. Lauren says, I quit. And then what happens
when you do? You're broke. What path do you to what path have
you to making money? And so
part of me wonders, is this book and this accusation someone
who needs money? Lauren bowed out because the heat in the kitchen
was too rough. I remember and this is fascinating too cuz this
is the space shoe head. Shuanad was friends with Lauren Southern.
They made content together. And then the left started calling
her out saying she's hanging out with a white nationalist. So
she issued the statement saying she's not friends with Lauren
Southern. It's just epic
Oh, dude. Dude, why? Why are these people like this? Why would
you say epic
It's epic cringe, guys.
Just hanging out with what?
There's like a limit to how long these people can be in media
for, right? It's just epic cringe. Show him disavowing Lauren
Southern. That's epic cringe, >> The white nationalist.
So, she issued the statement saying she's not friends with Lauren
Southern. It's just epic cringe. This is these are the people
in this space. Now, it breaks my heart a little bit to see all
of this stuff, to see that Lauren retired. We we did a documentary
with her, infringed recently, and it's not far right. It's not
crazy politics. I don't know why Lauren couldn't just be that.
We have offered to work with her and uh asked her if you want
to do more documentaries. She said, "No, there's never been any
acrimony. I still consider her to be uh a good friend." >> Hey,
I feel like Lauren, how many times can Lauren like be be like
the idiot in something, right? Like she got he got fooled by
Russia. Lauren got fooled by Russia.
But you had a lot more reason not to be fooled, Tim. At least
for her, it was like her friend. She was getting like a reasonable
salary, right? Like not a totally insane salary like you were.
She had way less reason to be suspicious than Tim did. I don't
know that she trusts him in general to go and do for him, right?
I feel like she's probably pretty she's pretty gunshy about collaborations.
>> And this whole thing, all of this breaks my heart. Also,
I have no idea how I don't know how aggressive Tim's been.
>> did we watch the Nick Fentes react? Yeah, we watched
that last night. That's the way uh it's kind of it was kind of
bad, right? Queen of the Q. Like, not bad. Not bad. Not bad.
It was kind of tame. I thought it was going to go way harder
than it did. I thought it was going to go way harder. I actually
thought it ended up being more tame than I expected. Uh the way
it goes, I suppose, you know, people change. I I I I got to be
honest. Maybe Lauren really does believe these things. I don't
know. But I just find it hard to believe to be honest. There's
no evidence. The story is salacious. And >> there wait
there is evidence though. I like this is the thing is do you
think Tim knows that al sorry actual justice warrior. I keep
thinking it's like alt justice warrior or something. Actual justice
warrior said hey I saw the medical report. I saw the police document
or something. He said he saw documents. I he said the medical
report for sure. I feel like he hinted at the police thing and
he's like I believe this. I believe this to be true. Like I asked
for these things because Lauren wanted me like Lauren came to
me about this and I asked for these things and I was given them
and I believe her allegation.
Why wouldn't you talk to him? Why wouldn't you talk to Shawn?
I feel like that would be incumbent on you to reach out to Shawn,
right? You're you've got a relationship with him. You could easily
do that. It's a huge part of the story. Wouldn't his opinion
and like his read on things be actually like foundational in
creating your opinion? >> And it's released right when
she's selling a book self-published on Amazon.
>> How many women have we seen do this? So, I'm sure Lauren
understands why people are not going to take this seriously.
>> I don't know if she thinks she's going to get Look,
Rolling Stone, wrote it up. And this is this is the ploy, right?
Are people on the right going to buy her book talking about her
time with the right? Probably not. What's the
>> What's the conflict? The adventures of Lauren. She's
uh now 30, I believe. She spent some time in the conservative
space during the first Trump term and then left. If you want
to get the left to buy a book, you do this. Rolling Stone will
write it up for you. People are going to want to read it. And
I wouldn't be surprised if the next move that we end up seeing
from Lauren, of course, may be pressed. She say she's not gonna
do it. Okay. So, she's not gonna be doing press on it. So, I
hope that's the case. I'll say lovey. I'll leave it there. Smash
the like button. Share the show with everyone. Stay tuned. We
got more segments coming up for you through I just I want to
see him. I bet basically just talking to actual justice war.
I wonder if Sean's posted about this at all. Let me check his
uh was it Sean Fitzgerald? I am Oh, hold on. I'll I'll find his
Twitter really quickly. Sean Fitzgerald.
I am Shawn 90. Check this guy out. I am Shawn 90. Did you say
anything else about this today? Epstein Schaefer. Oh, it's a
Brown Woo tweet. I'm sorry. This is silly. If anyone was born
to play Princess Zelda, it is Hunter Schaefer.
Hunter was quite literally not born to play this character. That's
just I mean that's just rage bait obviously.
Lauren releases all the tape chapters in full for free. In those
chapters, she claims that she went to the UK police, Canadian
police, and to a medical center within a week of the alleged
crime. Jeremy quote tweets screenshots from the very chapters
up for free and tells you the opposite. So he's defending her
on Twitter, which I think is probably difficult for him, right?
He's seen evidence that she hasn't or sorry that the world hasn't.
Everyone's reaction to this is entirely predictable. Prior to
making my video, I someone who is not a journalist, asked to
see every reference document. How many people didn't bother to
read the free relatively short chapters to know what to ask for,
let alone follow up? I produced the lengthy video uh this lengthy
video on the subject believe what you will but don't pretend
to your don't pretend based on your uh based your opinion but
don't pretend based your opinion on facts. You based your opinion
on facts if you didn't take any time to look. Yeah, it seems
reasonable. Okay. Okay. Have you watched the quartering reaction
yet? No, we have the quarterin reaction queued up. Let's take
a look. We've got that queued up. I will grab another tweet or
something though. I've got some other like uh some antagonistic
tweets.
So, I think it was Tommy Robinson or Andrew Tate quote tweeted
this and just said like, "She lies. She lies. She >> I
forget, but we we're just going to play this >> in a Ralph
video. Everyone, okay, let's Lauren, I tagged you and Destiny
on Twitter in a Ralph video. Everyone, okay, let's fine. We'll
talk about Ethan >> This is the rough thing is you kind
of have to like if people know your business and then you you
basically are forced to lie about it, like that's going to paint
you as a liar going forward. Everyone like wants me to engage
with the Ethan Ralph stuff. Everyone wants me to talk about it
and discuss the drama there, >> but there is no drama.
It's literally just Ethan Ralph inventing it out of thin air
for attention. There's like >> I got this stupid
drama. Drama. There's no drama there. >> There's no sub.
>> W Andrew Tate. Okay. W Andrew Tate. I Dude, drama. Drama.
>> Distance to anything. He just >> That's a joke.
That was satire. That's not real makeup to try to get people
to engage with it to try to cause like >> Oh, wait, wait,
wait. I think it was there's nothingness. There's nothing to
grab on to or talk about unless you want to talk about how he's
embarrassing himself, I guess. I don't know here. Sorry, I got
to focus the camera. A lot of people were like, is he going to
be in the manifesto? Is he going to be in the manifesto? Ethan
Ralph has never done anything in his life. He's never like gone
outside and engaged or like >> your family says this [__]
don't try to hide it. Nope. Nobody does. Either Ralph's never
Ether Ralph says I slept with Destiny because he's never gone
outside and he's never had human interaction. This is why I think
I wouldn't be good at this kind of lying. Okay, if you if you're
like caught and you need to lie about something, I don't think
I could do this where I'm like making fun of somebody for believing
something that's totally true about me. There's something I just
I can't do quite that. >> You know, gone to protests or
done anything significantly political. He's never been involved
in kind of the political movement. He just kind of sits on his
computer and like gossips. So, I've seen at least two times Ethan
Ralph getting his ass kicked on camera, Lauren. How many times
have you gotten beaten the up on camera, Lauren? Zero. Zero.
Sounds like Ralph's got more life experience than you, though.
Okay. >> Why do Like, what would I even include him for?
I He had no He had no level of importance to be included in the
>> She's right about Ralph. No, she's not. I've seen Ralph
get his ass kicked on camera twice at least. Maybe three times,
but twice for sure. Okay. There's the one where he fights uh
Riley,
right? And then there's the like he tries to break into their
house at night to go fight Riley. And then there's the other
one in Portugal where he gets his ass kicked. Okay. I've seen
him get kicked twice. What do you mean he doesn't go outside?
Can we watch this LS classic? What is it? Yeah, we can watch
this. We can watch this.
>> Um I I don't even know where to start with you. I mean,
do you even know who you're talking to? Yo, what's up? >> Do
Do you have any idea any idea who I
basically kind of a big deal.
>> Oh man, that's beautiful.
>> You listening? Okay. Grass grows, birds fly, sun shines,
and brother, I hurt people.
I'm a force of nature. If you were from where I was from, you'd
be dead.
It actually matches up so well. She's actually like a nerd. It
matches up so well to the original. If you haven't seen the original,
you should watch it just to know how closely it lines up. It's
actually pretty well done. Who is this? This is Lauren Southern
that was published on her sister's YouTube channel. What do you
mean cringe as it's just like a It's like a meme. 14 years ago,
by the way. 14 years ago. That is Lauren Southern. No, that's
Lauren Southern. Ah, it's not that cringe. Shut up. >> I
don't know, man. He's like, >> shut up. >> He's just
a lull cow. There's no there's nothing to talk about with Ralph.
And then if you talk about him, he becomes obsessed. Like actually
obsessed. I think I mentioned him like not even once on Twitter.
He was just responding to him and >> totally totally cringe
material there in that stream of Bull Two Legs. What are you
doing? >> He's just like obsessed. >> What are you
doing off the other day? He was like, "We need to find proof
that Lauren's a" and they get a photo and it's of me with a family
member like hugging on the shoulder and he's like, "Yeah, look
at this. This is like psychoanalyzing this photo of me with family.
It's just
really creepy, weird stuff. And this is what I mean. I just did
an interview with a guy named Josh the Cash from Wrong Opinion.
And he was like, you know, I like Josh. We've been friends for
a long time. But he was talking about how women and gay men,
they cause all this drama. And I'm like, no.
I'd say the >> proof, buddy. It's everywhere. I've been
a lot of people based on my stance of like defending Lauren on
this or saying like I probably believe Lauren on this have been
trying to send me proof that she like different random people
and it's like I'm sorry
uh gets insulted. Okay, that happens. The fact that she around
or people is not proof that she didn't get raped. I understand
why people think that. I understand how things have been done
that way. Okay, I understand that's like broadly a way people
deal with allegations,
but it's it's just not it's not
The main
>> ones are somehow men. Maybe they are gay. I don't know.
Maybe that's like the big secret here. Maybe they are all gay
men, but they are like it's all a lot of men claiming to be straight
that love to just gossip all day on the internet. I I don't know,
guys. Not good. Not good. So, we uh we won't address too much
of Ethan Ralph cuz there's nothing interesting. There's just
nothing there. It's a whole lot of nothing. All right. >> This
is Ralph accusing you of sleeping with Destiny, by the way. Unlucky.
Unlucky. Sorry. I'll play this cuz you're degenerates.
>> Absolutely abominable. Absolutely abominable. Where
the did she learn that word? I'm in Western Canada. I've never
heard someone say drama that way. Notice what I did there. Notice
what I did there? Drama. Okay, her and JJ McCulla both got to
go. Okay, they just fake this accent that doesn't even exist.
They say they're from BC. They're like, "Yeah, I'm from BC. This
is where this action this is where this accent comes from. Where
BC? I've been to BC. I have never met a person who speaks that
way. Where where do they speak that way?" It's crazy.
Anyway, we get the quartering video. Do I want to check out the
Rollo tweets first? I'm not totally
I think I'll I'll check up the Rolo tweets really quickly. Rolo
is still mad. He's trying to he's trying to get back. Okay. These
are screens from the conversations I had with Lauren Southern's
ex-husband in 2023 at Nero.
And so he he posts these and it's like he's mad that he kind
of got owned. Now, here's the thing. I don't know where does
this transition into how Lauren SCP him cuz like he says these
are all real conversations, right? But how did this turn into
like the part where she opted him? How did she get him talking
to an account she controlled would be my question. He's still
saying they're not fake, but like there was some scop here that
happened with him where they fed him a lot of information that
he was sort of like republishing. Not good. What was her involvement
with Andrew Tate? I have to be careful about this. Well, this
I can answer well as she used to cry about this to me as few
as a few times it seemed like it was getting out online or something.
Someone she had screwed over was trying to blackmail her back.
I believe Milo, again, I'm like a professional. I have I have
a normal professional life. What is all of this? It's just not
normal. So to really summarize, her and Tommy Robinson approached
Andrew Tate to contribute money to an alt-right documentary.
They went there and saw him personally in Romania. Lauren was
attracted to Tate and visit him a few times and started making
out and hanging out with him during the trip. She went back home
alone another time to secure money for or she went back alone
another time to secure money for the project. She got very drunk
and she was on her stomach on his bed and he got on top of her,
pulled her underwear off and was about to enter her from behind.
Lauren was drunk. resist and resisted. Told him no stop. Oh,
wait. He's not even denying the part. Told him no stop. Uh, got
on top of her. No. And stop and then locked her legs together.
Tate put her in a headlock and started to choke her out, telling
her to open her legs. When she when he finished, he said, "So
what? I you you can't do anything about it. Off." She was traumatized
by this by this all and had a few days later had a bender in
London with Tommy Robinson and her film crew. In the process,
she got wasted again and gave Tommy Robinson a [__]
despite him being married. Apparently, he told her they were
splitting up. She was ashamed of all of this and we had a long
detailed conversation about this as she would be in tears about
it as it was going on to come out as on socials at different
times. I remained supportive supportive and caring. It was before
we were together. She's a self-inflicted damaged woman mate all
for fame. It's actually sad. Oh, and she states she got herpes
from him. These are all things she has explicitly stated to me.
H tell me about Destiny. Lauren uses people to get what she wants.
She comes across sincere. So I would say given that that came
out and that seems to almost entirely align with her actual allegations,
right? I think it's that lends some credence here. Unfortunately,
as much as we don't like Rolo, that lends some credence to like
whatever's going on here being true, right? That either this
is Lauren or it's somebody close to Lauren. But the allegation
is almost one to one. It's very close. I don't know how much
that lends because it sounds like literally sorry. I mean it
it lends sorry it lends credence towards this being actually
Lauren's husband and not somebody fake.
Right. So I think what happened was these texts were getting
out and they did a whole thing where they like totally discredited
Rolo.
Right. They totally discredited Rolo.
And I think it's possible it seems possible that she he was literally
talking to her husband. Right. Destiny got her pregnant. Um,
well, I don't know if that's involved here. We'll see. We'll
we'll read more. But I would say I don't know how how do you
get like the the truth of like this allegation or or like this
allegation lining up so closely. These are messages from her
ex-husband. That's what Rolo says. But again, I maybe we have
to go back and watch the Britney Venty thing because I could
have sworn that they used this exact email to like trick Rolo
and get him to publish like a bunch of really up wrong. But now
I don't know. Now it's like did did we get counter did we get
double sciopt
like none of us believe Rolo now because of that but actually
I don't even know okay we'll read this tell me about destiny
Lauren uses people to get what she wants she comes across sincere
about this as she doesn't realize she what she is doing or as
if she doesn't realize she is doing it basically once your utility
is done she just forgets about you that's why she has very few
friends and struggles to maintain relationships with people of
any kind Destiny was her ticket to getting back into the YouTube
game as a somewhat reformed med alt-rider in my opinion. I had
received information that they were hanging out a lot uh when
her US travel ban was lifted. They then started sleeping with
each other as he is in some kind of relationship like that. Lauren
then got pregnant and it was a girl. They then just started formalizing
their relationship as I guess there is a kid involved. I do not
know what happened to this child or anything moving forward since
however uh since however since being told she has seen Tim Pool
or he has given her a job or something. So like this part seems
totally crazy to me. I don't believe this. So, is it possible
that they used the Andrew Tate thing to make Rolo bite? I actually
have no idea cuz like I could go back. It seemed like from what
I remember the Britney Venty thing like they they seem to have
some proof that they were corresponding with Rolo. So, I I literally
don't know now. Now I'm very confused again. What actually happened
here? What's the deal? Can anybody tell me what the deal is?
Lauren and Britney told Destiny they were missing with messing
with Rolo and he shouldn't say or do anything.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I Dude, I don't know. I don't know. I'm
I think Destiny getting her pregnant is fake. Yeah, I don't think
that's real either. I just can't imagine it was real,
but I don't know. I don't know how to Man, I don't know how to
parse this. Destiny lied and Lauren lied. Rollers has been after
the truth. Don't let your old orbiters distract you from the
truth. Okay, Bacto. I have no idea what happened. That's why
I just said we should go back and look. Pregnancy stuff was disinfo.
Yeah, I think so. But I don't know. Like it could be that maybe
this guy was told this stuff or something. I I'll see. We'll
see if Rolo posts some more stuff that's like related to this.
If there's anything else that could come out that makes him seem
more credible. We could maybe if we want we could check out the
Britney Venty stuff later, too. Seems possible. Uh, how is this
W? She's literally corroborating the story I related from her
ex-husband in June 2023 that she, Destiny, and Venty forged ultrasound
record, medical records to discredit me and suppress what I was
revealing at the time. They trolled you, dummy, and it was brilliant.
I believe for a second Tate.
Like it's possible they included some real stuff in here like
the the Tate thing, right? Just to with just to like basically
make Brolo bite cuz maybe he'd heard this behind the scenes.
Sounds like they wrapped the Destiny. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Izzy Mandius. That might be what they did. Or they were covering
up her ex talking to Rolo. I know. Now I need to go see their
evidence and stuff and compare it and figure it out. Anyway,
we'll watch the quartering stuff and then I'll decide. I'll make
a call at some point if we're going to go through that whole
Britney Venty video or not. >> 4. Here's the thing. I just
don't believe the the pregnancy thing was real. So, like, why
did that get >> 50th time with a brand new invention. This
time it is uh a book. A book in >> a brand new invention.
A book. when she makes heinous allegations with no evidence and
she has her little simp army uh already preset up and um running
interference for her. Now, there's a couple of things you need
to know about Lauren Southern. She was extremely popular during
the quote unquote skeptic era of YouTube. I don't know if many
of my viewers even know when who that is when that was but this
is what saw the rise of like Armored Skeptic which is no longer
active I don't think Sargon which is still very active and and
thriving there were a lot of skeptic type chat well yeah Private
Huff that's exactly the thing is like you mix in truth with the
lies so he can confirm the truth with other people and then the
lies seem more credible what is his head movement I don't know
dude it's like Elon and the Khole head movement else 99% of them
are
Carl
um you know and shoon head wasn't necessarily a skeptic but also
got like lumped into that are basically the only people who are
still culturally
>> Lauren Southern was one of those people in that area
in that era and gained a lot of fame you know kind of exposing
you know hypocrisy pronoun nonsense.
If I look at her most popular videos, obviously you have, you
know, science, her farmlands documentary was very good, I think.
Um, you know, she would go to London and and, you know, reveal
what was going on there. >> London Mosque called the police
on me, uh, about with the Muslims,
you know, all this kind of stuff. And, um, good work. And she
was just a kid at the time, like in her early 20s, right? Well,
a lot of time has passed since seven or eight years ago when
she was wildly popular and she's popped up a few times here or
there. Most of you know uh again this right-wing trad,
you know, said she was a big proponent of the trad
because she was also hooking up with Destiny who um was the is
probably the most vile human alive. Um and you know, that was
kind of the end of her >> Yeah. Let him cook. Let him cook.
Let him cook for a second. >> In my book, like you have
zero standards if you're sleeping with Destiny. He said that
Cory Comparatory, the fireman, who was at a Trump rally, deserved
what happened to him. Uh he's Oh, and fun fact, apparently that
is the thing that finally shattered their friendship or relationship
or whatever the they had. Apparently they
uh Hold on. I I saw this earlier. Where is it? Hold on. Uh Destiny
Lauren Southern, can I find this this screenshot on Twitter here
that I found before?
There was like a part where there's a part from the book where
they actually say she says Lauren says that she her relationship
with Destiny was broken
when
Destiny did the firefighter tweet. Like that was the thing that
shattered their relationship. She couldn't talk to him anymore
after that. Somebody if you can find it send it to me. All sorts
of heous things about the kids from the camp in Texas that passed
away that they deserved it. Things like of that nature. Maybe
that particular I'm a little fuzzy with some sort of NordVPN
thing. Destiny is maybe the worst human being on the planet.
Uh intellectually dishonest to uh the nth degree. And this is
who Lauren Southern was in love with. Uh she was married to a
That's it. It wasn't doxing your kid. No, it was the uh Wait,
that had that happened yet? No, that wouldn't have happened yet.
No, that wouldn't have happened. That happened later. Now, he
did retweet her allegation. So, I did see that. But hold on.
Let me see if I can find this here. I'm looking for the whole
thing. Where's it at? I agent.
And she is a serial liar. She is also in several private DM groups
I happen to know of with prominent female right-wing people.
Um and they often coordinate um responses, tweets and and uh
and narratives, people like actual Justice Warrior, Lauren Southern,
Sydney Watson, uh Hillary uh Crowder. They're all in these private
DM groups. And uh I wish I could tell you more about that because
it truly is vile. But I keep giving one of those people a chance
to be a decent human being before I completely release all of
that stuff. >> We'll read this page. This is from an article.
I think it's got excerpts. Anyone who tries to make sense of
this is not real life without at least a working knowledge
of of its setting and principles. Hold on. He has nothing. Yeah,
he's he's it's the quartering. Okay. It's not meant to be intelligent
commentary. Okay.
Uh at least a working knowledge of its setting and principal
characters is bound to find it confusing. The book skips back
and forth across the timeline, blending Southern's own reflections
and her accounts of events in a loose narrative only occasionally
anchored by dates. We can infer that Southern assumes her readers
are already sufficiently marinated in the relevant lore to know
who figures such as Steve Bannon, Tommy Robinson, and Andrew
Tate are. And while these have received enough mainstream press
coverage to be wellknown even beyond political fandom, it takes
someone truly up in the ears in online politics discourse to
know who Steven Banell is, let alone grasp the significance of
her having had a relationship with him. Vanell, also known as
Destiny, is a leftwing streamer of similar standing to Lauren
or Sor Southern, but for the other team, having met and debated
a few times early in their careers, Southern recounts a friendship
developing gradually between them after her marriage ended, a
relationship that eventually became intimate. When in late 2024,
the relationship was leaked, fans uh leaked, fans were shocked,
and bewildered. From a fan perspective, it was unthinkable to
consider any kind of relationship developing between the respective
folky of two fandoms so diametrically opposed as Southerns and
Destiny's. But in Southern's telling, having both grown up in
the digital panic panopticon
and served as the avatar for huge fan communities, they had a
surprising amount in common. Even so, as Southern tells it, even
the camaraderie occasioned by their shared experience of life
in the digital fishbowl eventually fell victim to the relentless
incentive to take ever more polarized positions. In a scene surely
too out there to be fabricated, she recounts her final showdown
with Banell as taking place on the night Donald Trump was shot
in the apartment of Southern's friend, MAGA influencer Ashley
St. Claire, who was then pregnant with Elon Musk's baby. Banell
had made several provocative posts about the assassination attempt,
which prompted a bitter stand-up row, an irreparable
rupture of their friendship. Her sorrow was palpable. I'd come
here hoping for clarity about my work, about the internet, maybe
even about whether I still had a friend, but now I just feel
felt more fractured than before, more alone. Everything felt
impossibly.
So yeah, apparently they were hanging out together around the
time he was making those tweets. Is this like uh people who share
your political opinions just got murdered and I'm going to celebrate
that on Twitter? Riv.
Yeah.
Impressive. Vanell in a room with Elon's baby apparently. That's
weird. That that I had no idea about. That was uh pretty crazy
to see that. But interesting interesting stuff. >> Anyway,
this is the quarter. >> Now she's come back. Okay, so she's
a YouTuber. Um she was provocative. Um she comes out with a book.
It hasn't, you know, her YouTube channel is basically dead. her
last video she uploaded got 30,000 views and it was almost a
year ago. Um, she's tried to reinvent herself >> This guy
probably has better videos if he doesn't have if he doesn't get
good views. Listen, he's doing better than Lauren. He's got a
lot of views. This is actually not a dying channel. He he posts
a lot of videos, okay? These are not bad views given the volume,
okay? Given the volume, >> not bad videos.
Um, you know, all of this stuff. And Lauren Southern, much like
many of the other female conservatives, I thought, was a friend
of mine, only to find out later that they had a secondary DM
group where they would talk garbage about me all the time. But,
you know, that's for a different video. So, >> wait, what?
Almost a year ago. Um, she's tried to reinvent herself now as
some sort of food expert. Um, you know, all of this stuff. And
Lauren Southern, much like many of the other female conservatives,
I thought, was a friend of mine only to find out later that they
had a secondary DM group where they would talk garbage about
me all the >> Oof. Oof. That's rough, dude. That's >> That's
for a different video. So, all of the women in your movement
hate you? I wonder how that could possibly come to >> Yes.
I find in my personal interactions with Lauren Southern, she's
been wildly manipulative. Um, and she wants to sell this new
book. Um, where she admits to, you know, doing drugs and um,
coke binges and all this kind of stuff. And then she had a mental
breakdown, a psychotic break. But in order to sell her book,
she has decided, hey, I'm going to release a chapter of said
book where I talk about how I hooked up with Andrew Tate. But
I'm going to spin it a little bit and I'm going to say that,
well, yeah, I was hanging out with Andrew Tate. Yeah, I slept
I I let him sleep in the bed with me. Yeah, we were making out.
Yeah, we were making out the next morning as people saw. But
that's not in the book. I don't I think I have not seen her dispute
that. But she does say Tommy Robinson lied about her. She really
cowardly implied that some sort of horrible essay had happened.
Now, she also claims that she went to local hospitals and local
law enforcement and they just didn't No, she didn't claim that.
That is misinformation. She did not claim she went to a local
hospital. She did not claim she went to local law enforcement.
Both of those things are incontrovertibly false based on the
actual chapters. You just didn't read them because you are a
[__]
He literally did not read. He failed to read. He is a Willy M
tier illiterate. Just all you got to do is read. It's not hard
to read.
It takes a little bit of time, but it's not difficult to read.
>> Care about it. Which I find really hard to believe given
how desperate the UK is to prosecute Andrew Tape. Given how progressive
Canada is. I find it extraordinarily difficult to believe that
she went to these law enforcement places and they simply told
her, "See you later." Now, maybe. >> Wait, hold on. I think
it's incredibly obvious that most law enforcement places, somebody's
insulted another country, they'd say, "Please leave. We we can't
do anything about that. Sorry. Obviously. Now, I think where
she went to the hospital, I think that was in England. I'm not
100% sure, but I believe that was in England. >> She did.
And maybe there was more to the story because she says, "You
know what really happened? I reluctantly reached out to UK authorities
the next day feeling it was the right thing to do only to be
met with indifference. They told me an investigation going for
>> Yeah. That's not local authorities,
>> Why did you reach out to UK authorities? Because the
next day, I believe they went and got on a plane and flew back
to the UK. where I had been explicitly warned about police corruption.
I went deeper into a disassociative state as a result, feeling
certain there would never be a resolution. I wonder if she was
wearing a wedding ring at this time when she was hanging out
with Andrew Kate or not, if she was still married. Let's see.
I'm not sure. She wasn't married. It was in 2018.
It's so not hard to get any of the facts on this before you comment.
It's so easy to not sound like a idiot here, dude. Um, you know,
attempts involadian authorities led to similar dead ends. It's
almost like I wonder if she didn't have any evidence whatsoever.
Um, so she did, you know, as I as I often critique >> What
evidence would she have?
>> Critique I often have, you know, hey, how come you didn't
file a police report? Well, she allegedly
spoke to people. I don't know if there's any kind of official
report because she never released that. So, I don't Okay. Do
you trust actual Justice Warrior? Actual Justice Warrior received
these materials. You could reach out to him. I just feel like
if Actual Justice Warrior says, "I was I reviewed these. I asked
questions about it. Lauren shared these things with me." Um,
I'm putting my like reputation behind this. I feel like you just
reach out to him, right, and say, "Hey, I I saw this or watch
this video." >> Oh, no. And why hasn't she said anything
about it in the last 5 years? The only way anyone found out about
this, okay, is through her selling a book. >> No. Also
stupid.
Everybody who everybody who's in the know tapped into gossip
in these spheres knew about it because her former camera guy
literally talked about it in 2020. Tommy Robinson talked about
it in 2020. A bunch of people have talked about this. This has
been pseudo public knowledge for almost 5 years now. It was the
end of 2023 or sorry the end of 2019 I believe when this was
first brought up. It's hard to watch that haw video. That is
fair. Yes, it is difficult to watch. That's true. >> By
the way, Hillary Cler Crowder, >> it's just it's really
sad to me that he just has none of the facts and he feels comfortable
making a video. It's got 30,000 views in 7 hours. Like where
do people this guy used to run a news organization? How did he
found a news organization? He doesn't even understand like the
first thing about anything. I just do drama and I was like, "Oh,
I I should probably go read some of this or have some idea of
the timeline." I went and looked stuff up before I covered it,
right? It's not that difficult. It's not hard. It's very easy.
>> Claimed that I was divorced, that I've been divorced
for 2 years from my from my wife. Uh she stated that as fact
on Twitter last night in defense of Lauren Southern. That's just
the type of women we're dealing with here. By the way, this again,
she claimed I want to get the actual passage because
this is where it's really cowardly. Here's just what she admits
to. I'd rather not give a detailed account, so keep it simple.
Andrew Tate carried me back to the hotel room and asked me to
sleep beside him. Oh, real quick, guys. If you like the content,
go ahead. Uh, donate. Donate. We need more time on the stream.
We got 30 minutes left. I'm just doing a quick shill here, not
the full shill, okay? You can sub on kick. You can give subs
on kick. You could sub on Twitch. You could sub with your Twitch
Prime. You could give subs on Twitch if you wanted to. If you
really just want to give subs, give money, do it through kick.
955 split. Way better. Okay. There's multiple TTS messages. Okay.
exclamation point. Donate in the chat. We'll give you both links.
You can have more time to the stream. Every dollar you donate
goes towards more time on the stream. So, thank you very much
for all your support, guys. We can take >> I said yes.
I was incredibly intoxicated. And some part of me convinced myself
that because he was Tommy Robinson's friend, it wasn't particularly
dangerous. It was a poor decision, but it happened. He kissed
me. I wasn't expecting it, and I wasn't >> I don't know
why. Why is he reading it in this voice? Dude, I feel like just
uh it's it's a bit of a bizarre thing to read it in this voice.
Hold on. Somebody sent me a a take. There's like a there's some
kind of genius over here. Okay. A genius, unparalleled genius
who gave his take on this. Give me two seconds. I'll pull it
in just a second. >> Had to upload it to streamable. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. You heard him. You heard his voice. You
heard his voice. We had a JF take. We got a JF take. The JF take
has hit the timeline, guys. >> They seek trouble and they
are addicted to it and then they try to ride on that trouble.
And as a libertarian, it's hard it's hard to say, well, she said
no, so it's right. And I I would like to take you by the hand
tonight and convince you that basically, and this is my philosophical
libertarian position,
>> there are some rules that must occur.
Okay. This guy's awesome. This guy is so
Listen,
I don't have the power. I don't have the power level required
to make that statement. Okay, that was nuts.
Holy [__] >> This is my philosophical libertarian
There are some
that must occur.
>> Oh my god,
I love this guy. I love this guy. That is the funniest clip.
Holy [__]
>> Oh, it feels bad. Listen, it's criminal that JF doesn't
get views and the quartering does and the Quartering has a YouTube
channel. Okay, that's actually criminal. We should all be super
disappointed in the world for that fact being true. Okay. Jesus.
>> For it. Really? Is that what you do? You lay in bed
with a man probably in your, you know, undergarments cuz you're
going to bed. That's and then a kiss would be totally okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Then she said I kissed him back briefly. Then I told
him I wanted to go to sleep. I was extraordinarily tired. So
she was extraordinarily tired, extraordinarily intoxicated. But
she remembers every single detail around this. H interesting.
Do you want to go further? I said no very clearly multiple times.
I tried to pull his hands off me. He put his arm around my neck
and began strangling me unconscious. I tried to fight back. He
repeatedly did this. Every time he would get enough consciousness
to pull his arms. I'd prefer not to share the rest. It's pretty
obvious now. I find it pretty. >> Please. Okay. Hey, if
you guys weren't watching earlier, Tim Pull's take on that was
it's not obvious. What if What if it was just rough making out?
What if they were just roughly making out? It's not obvious what
happened. I don't think the quartering can actually get under
that bar. I think Tim P placed the bar firmly on the ground and
somehow like kicked it into the ground. I don't think you can
possibly get under the bar. Okay, so we'll see if the quarterin
can try. We'll see. I don't believe you can. >> Consciousness
to pull his arms. I'd prefer not to share the rest. It's pretty
obvious. Now, I find it pretty pretty interesting that she specifically
does not say that he did any kind of essay to her. I find it
pretty cowardly because she's using the implication that he did,
right, to sell a $25 book, which by the way, only an idiot would
buy. Andrew Tate, of course, response. Juice the chapter. >> Guys,
I need you to juice that tweet I just threw in the kick chat.
Okay? Juice that tweet. Juice that tweet. Juice that tweet. Juice
that tweet. Sorry, I was I was tweeting. I find it pretty cowardly
because she's using the implication that he did, right, to sell
a $25 book, which by the way, I prefer not to share the >> I
need I need to catch it from the beginning. I was just writing
that tweet really quickly.
>> Pretty interesting that she specifically does not say
that he did any kind of essay to her. >> Oh, we got the
we got the [__] take again. Okay, he didn't at least
say that it doesn't mean that. But we've got the [__]
take again that
we've got the total [__] take that you can't defame
if you don't say the precise words.
No, it's obvious what she's suggesting here. It is obvious to
anybody what she's suggesting here. Okay.
The reason she's saying she doesn't want to speak more on it.
uh not just from this from later in the book when she says my
allegation matched extremely closely to a person who did accuse
him of rap who did actually get him charged for rape right that
it it corroborates the exact same pattern of behavior. Yeah.
So like it's not a myster it's not a mystery. You just have to
read all of it and then you understand. I find it pretty cowardly
because she's using the implication that he did right to sell
a $25 book which by the way only an idiot would buy. Andrew Tate,
of course, response. Choose the chapter about me to release quote
for free to get attention so she can sell her memoirs of promiscuity.
Coincidence? I'm sure. I'm glad you admit you're a drug addict
in the post. That might explain why you forgot all about the
text messages you sent begging to see me again. Should I release
them in my book? Too begged for me. Here's Tommy
>> who I have a lot of trust. >> We we read that
on I think is a good man who, you know, maybe hasn't done the
best things, but he was there. He was in the next room. Here's
what Tommy Robinson, by the way, defending a Muslim, which takes
a lot. >> Here's a here's a horrible fact. Okay, I was
there when I traveled to Romania. >> Is he saying that?
Wait, is he saying that for is he saying that for Tommy Robinson
or him? Cuz it's definitely true for Tommy Robinson, but sorry
to defend a Muslim. Yeah, Tommy Robinson is a very good man.
>> I was in the hotel room next door. When I walked out
in the morning when we were leaving, Lon's at the door kissing
him. Okay. So, when you read what she says there, like he's raped.
>> Yeah. Uhhuh. Like he's done. Yeah. >> Complaining.
That's what she's >> be kissing him on his door and then
get in the car and message him the whole way. Insanity. Absolutely.
>> Interesting. Interesting. Here's a statement on behalf
of Andrew Tate from uh uh his lawyer. Andrew Tate unequivocally
repudiates his pathetic filth pedal by Lauren Southern in her
pitable tone. This is not real life. A washed up nobody loser
memoir if there ever was was one. No evidence supports her claim.
There is so-called free chapter released nothing but an evil
marketing play. A sensational teaser engineered to propel sales
of her book by parasiting Andrew's fame. Southern is a fade faded
relic, destitute and pathetic. She told me she was destitute,
too. She told me she had no money when I then told me the offer
I gave her, which was more than generous. Wasn't enough money.
Anyway, uh scavenging scraps through um Andrew's renowned we've
witnessed this wretched ploy countless times. Stale, inepid,
utterly contemptable. Now, I know a lot of people in this video
are going to say, "Ooh, you're sipping for Andrew Tate." I'm
sipping for the truth. Okay. I think it's entirely likely that
she had consensual BDSM interactions with Andrew Tate. He appears
to be into that. He appears to be into BDSM. Um, and she's spinning
it, this is my opinion, as a horrible case. She provided no evidence
of, you know, contacting the authorities. Maybe she did, maybe
she didn't. Um, men, this is the playbook to destroy your life.
Turn consensual hookup into non-conensual via retroactive accusations,
weaponization for extortion, lawsuits, and payouts. No man, husband,
father, or son is safe from this venom. Where mutual encounters
become traps for financial ruin. This is a clearing call to men
everywhere. >> I dude, this is such an embarrassing post
with the with the thesaurus. Like, it's just weird. It's such
a weird post. >> The war rages with false accusations weaponized
to shatter lives. Twisting consensual bonds into extortion snares.
Everything is on the line. Rise now demand proof. Yeah. >> Yeah.
The BDSM thing. I don't I don't understand why you would say
like,
>> okay, how is this not worse? How is this not worse than
like the worst simp who just is believe all women? This is worse.
You're just doing believe all men except that men have talked
about and are accused multiple times of the crime you're defending
them from. Like this is just a total like you're totally shutting
your pattern recognition off to try to I don't know suck this
guy for no >> I would love some proof. >> This is
a girl that's basically been with half of the people I know in
the conservative space. But I won't make fun of her for that
because those guys rapist. True. >> Participating in degeneracy.
>> You know, Andrew Kate hooking up with her is a generate.
Um Paul Joseph Watson allegedly hooking up with her also degenerate.
Um I have there is a long list of men just in the conservative
space that she's been with. But the one that is probably the
worst is Destiny. Um, and you know, this is a woman that's reportedly
um, worked with organizations uh, provided information against
Gavin McInness, provided information to Antifa. This is alleged
from Milo in a long documentary in a long article series that
essentially ruined her career. If you want to know more about
who Lauren Southern really is, you can read what Milo wrote about
her in this article that ended her career. Okay, this was, you
know, um, where's the article? I think it was called like the
Grifters. Here it is. Meet the Klepto queens of the British farright.
This is the video that ended, this is the Twitter thread that
basically ended Lauren Southern's career. Um, you can read all
about the claims that Milo makes here that she was informing
against people on the right and doing all this kind of stuff.
You can reread all about it. This is, you know, again, apparently,
you know, apparently
the right is now the believe all women side of things. Absolutely
pathetic behavior. Hope you enjoyed this video. If you did, make
sure you leave a like on it. If you haven't yet, make sure you
subscribe or follow. >> Shut up.
Okay. Apparently, maybe we should check out this thread. I don't
know. It's like a Milo thread, so it's a little a little iffy.
It's a little iffy. Yeah, it's a little iffy. Milo is not exactly
the most trustworthy guy. Okay, Milo a little bit. Okay, what
do we got? What else do we got here? We got anything else on
this? Oh, there is one last thing. Hold on. There's one last
thing. We got the whole JF Gary. >> We have >> We
have the Okay.
Okay.
These people these people are insane,
dude. I didn't think we had a whole contingent of people on Twitter
who are just like, "You know what, JF? You're correct. You're
totally correct. Here's here's Lauren Southern with bruises and
Tate laughing and she's saying Andrew Tate funded that article.
Uh she was saying that Andertate funded some article for Milo
about her. So it might be okay. All right. A full libertarian
principled argument for why claims must sometimes be ignored
even when you believe a technical may have occurred as it applies
in the case of Lauren
>> Uh we have the Lauren. >> All right, I'm going
to hit play on this. I'm going to use a bathroom real quick and
just grab some water and we're going to go. Okay. >> Certain
case to examine today and we'll be going through in depth. Uh
it's a it's a it's a case that illustrates so much of what female
psychopathology
can be. People like Lauren Sutton, they are they are magnets
for trouble.
They live uh extremely dangerous lifestyles for themselves and
they like it and they don't they don't know exactly. They they
seek trouble. They put themselves in trouble, but they don't
know that they have this kind of addiction to trouble such that
they will always cause drama for themselves.
And it's amazing to me because this little gang, Tommy
uh
Lauren Southern,
they they don't get much they don't get much hit piece mocking
their private lives the way I do. Uh and you know if you look
at the amount of hit pieces on my private life. >> Okay.
Okay.
As uh you know the RCMP investigation into JF is a hit piece
on his private life. Okay. That's what it is. We all know that's
what it is.
>> What's a technical The definitions on it aren't aren't
exact from what I'm seeing. I JF will lay it out. Okay. JF will
lay out his entire case here. All right. I believe in him >> and
the attacks on what is really just a monogamous lifestyle. You
compare with them and you don't get much you don't get much on
their private life. There are some there are some forum posters
who will spread stuff about Lauren Southern and complain about
it. But you don't get mainstream media attacks on their personal
lives. >> It will just be your pain. >> That's fascinating
to me because they
>> Not even a message. Oh, those are my favorite donations.
Just have some money.
Two. Thank you, Anonymous. Thank you. Two more hours on the stream.
Let's
>> We're talking two giant coke addicts here. Uh Lauren
Southern addicted to
uh psychotic. >> So, I think she does claim to have done
Coke in the memoir. >> Uncontrollable, delusional,
dangerous for herself.
Uh and Tommy Robinson same thing and yes she slept with Destiny.
Uh we are talking about uh a social escala >> and that
is that is on its own. Okay that's basically like being a psychotic
drug addict.
She is a psychotic drug addict. Okay. And she slept with Destiny.
These are the two pillars against her.
And we need to talk in depth about accusations and how how they
are used by these extreme social escalators because Lauren Sern
could have been happy with what she got in terms of attention
already in her life. She didn't need to go on a on ausation
book tour, but she does. And why? It's because they can't help.
They need this attention. It gives them social status because
deep down inside these people are nothing. O nothing. And that
that's a very different type of celeb than I am because deep
down inside I know I'm something. I could be on the streets.
I could lose everything.
JF's strength comes from within. Okay.
His that's why he had the strength. Lauren Southern could never
take her spouse into the woods and leave them to die. Okay? Because
she doesn't have strength that comes from within. She doesn't
have it. >> I could not have a show and I could have a
small show like I do right now. And I I will be unshakable as
to what I have. And if I go on a crazy night, it won't be I might
buy a bottle of red wine and I might do some more math. That
That's a crazy night for me.
>> Does this guy I want to read a JF math proof. Do we
have JF math proofs? Do those exist? Uh, somebody asked, "Would
you say she's met or tasted both extremes of the red pill and
blue pill ar blue pill archetypes?" I suppose so. >> But
yet these people, they they flock to trouble.
They seek trouble and they are addicted to it. And then they
try to ride on that trouble. And as a libertarian, it's hard.
It's hard to say, "Well, she said no, so it's right." And I I
would like to take you by the hand tonight and convince you that
basically and this is my philosophical libertarian position.
>> Oh no, it's the line. >> There are some rings
that must occur. They are in the market of interactions. Okay,
we have a necessary minimum on Okay, there is a necessary minimum
to to keep the market regulated. Okay, people get way out of
line without these required
instances of rape. All right, >> neither good nor bad.
They are they are to be excluded from the normal offense that
you would have at rape. To be clear, I'm totally and >> are
you though?
Sounds I don't know, bro. How do you put those two lines together
back to back? There are some rips that must occur. To be clear,
I am totally anti-rep.
And to me, if a woman says no, even after turning you on, even
after saying
giving you all the signs that she wants, even after kissing you.
Oh, I see. His argument is going to be, listen, if she's going
to give you every signal that she wants to have with you and
then just say no at the end, then she must morally morally you
have to you have to rape. You have to make sure that she understands
that that signal cannot be given out or she will be infinitely.
If you do not, you are risking her being more in the future.
Okay, it is actually JF is about to inc introduce the libertarian
argument for the cage.
>> If a woman says no, technically it's wrong.
But I will make the argument that because of the philosophy of
unclean hands doctrine that there are people who put themselves
in criminal trouble in ways that they should be considered part
just to be clear unclean hands only applies to the same offense
in the legal sense. Okay, maybe in philosophy if you've done
something bad you but that's just an eye for an eye. Unclean
hands is like you do the exact crime to other people so you don't
get to cry when that crime is done to you. part of the >> so
Lauren Southern would have to >> crime rather than victims
of the crime because Okay. So the whole story is this and I'll
get to uh I'll get to other news later because this is important.
The whole story is Lauren Southern
go is brought by Tommy Robinson.
Um, Lauren Southern is brought by Tommy Robinson toward
and rotate and his crypto guys because they want some investment
in their news company. So, so of course when you're a big YouTuber
like this, you're looking for this kind of big guy who's millionaire
who could give you a million in a shot who could give you half
a million to get you
So they get they travel to end rotate
and end rotate shows off his cars, brags. He has his crypto bros
working for him building Ponzi schemes for his coins. You know
what I like about this? Okay, I will say Jeff's going to have
a insane take. Okay, the take is going to be insane, but at least
he read. At least he's not illiterate. Okay.
How are you going to explain the Ponzi schemes and what how she
references them, how she talks about them, and not have read
the article or not have read the free chapters? At least he read
it. Okay,
that puts him immediately above the quartering Tim Pool. Okay,
>> that's how she describes it.
>> And so, so first you are with a coke addict because
you're addicted to coke. You're traveling with a coke addict
who can find your coke-
which is Tommy Robinson anywhere on the planet and you you end
up visiting this millionaire guy Andrew Tate uh who's saying
yeah maybe we can throw some money at your news company to get
you started an investment >> quote unquote
>> investment quote unquote >> she ends up being
separated from Tommy Robinson and this is the first you could
have avoided this you could have avoided going in the third world
where there will be no law especially not so this is going to
all be true like but the thing to me is I didn't feel like I
needed to criticize it sounds like she basically criticized it
herself right she criticized her own behavior multiple times
so I don't I didn't feel the need to go and criticize all of
her bad decisions because she does so herself >> for a
local who's that rich you could have avoided going to a country
where you have no due process,
but you liked going there because you were on a coke binge with
your friend Tommy Robinson
and oh, let's talk money and let's act big. Not being raped by
Andrew Tate may be the easiest challenge
in the entire world. Okay. Oh my god.
I mean, that's true. Okay. Never be within the thousand miles
of Andrew Tate. You can't be by him. Okay. It's pretty easy.
Pretty not difficult.
I I agree. Technically in a vacuum that would be easy to do.
Like seriously, it it is so easy
not to get raped by Andrew Rutate that at this point I I considered
a noncriminal.
It is because here's the thing, >> dude. Suppose that you
were
>> investigating a murder and you have two people who you
think have participated to the murder. >> One man, >> one
woman. The man tells you, >> "Hold on, let him cook. Let
him cook." >> The the man, you know, given the evidence,
you you seem to understand that, yeah, you know, maybe the man
pulled the trigger. And now you're investigating the woman, and
the woman tells you this.
Well, I did buy the gun
and we did speculate about, you know, killing that person
and I did hand him the gun and then we had and then during I
told him, "Do you promise me that you will kill him? Are you
going to kill him?"
And I handed him the gun. In fact, I loaded the gun myself.
So, the unfortunate thing here is JF has already smuggled in
the actual differentiating factor, right? He's already smuggled
it in. I realize a lot of people are just laughing that he's
a goofy funny sounding guy, right? But the issue is Lauren, there
is no case in that case where you're ignorant to the murder.
In this case, Lauren may have been ignorant. There is a claim
that she could be ignorant to having or ignorant that she she
didn't know that this guy was going to try to her or force her
or that she didn't want and she might have still said yes to
some of the previous things. Right? So, he's already but he's
already smuggled in the the intent part or the knowing part and
so now he can't be wrong. Just got to point that out early because
he's going to give analogy that seems to line up 100%. >> I
went to buy the bullets, loaded the magazine, put it in the gun,
and then I gave him the gun. And in fact, I tricked the victim
into showing up at a meeting so that he would get a clear line
of shot
and then he shot him. But before he shot him, I said no. Before
Before my my new boyfriend shot my old boyfriend,
I yelled, "No, don't do it." I changed I had changed my mind.
Now what would you say about the degree of criminal
guilt of the woman who tells you this? >> Wait, what would
you what would you say about the degree of guilt of the man who
shot the guy?
>> She is fully participating to the crime of murder. It
wouldn't even be accessory at this point. It would be she would
get charged with this fear pig.
>> Reban Rubin donated $3. Does this whole situation leave
a bad tate in your >> It does. It does. Reuben Ruben, thank
you for the >> same murder charges as the guy who pulled
the trigger.
Does it matter that she said no at the end? No, it doesn't. Because
even if you weren't consenting
at the inevitable conclusion of each of your action in the last
week as you were buying the gun, buying the bullets, putting
them planning the murder, all of this is enough. It's enough
>> to consider that you consented to the murder even if
you had a change of mind at the last minute. And so this is where
you can be you can be part of a crime against someone else.
>> But you couldn't ever say that because um you couldn't
ever say that this doesn't work cuz murder is like a automatically
wrong. Uh the analogy doesn't work. I thought he'd do better
on this. >> But here's where where where the human brain
has difficulty translating this into the accusation domain.
>> You cannot >> That's true. I am human and I'm
having trouble translating. >> Also, be entrapping someone
into committing a crime against you, >> but doing it so
obviously and in a way that shows so much of your consent across
the different steps that essentially there's no crime at the
end, even if you yell no at the end. Because if there was a crime,
>> this also this is this might work if basically you were
telling them to murder you, right?
This maybe could you could argue it maybe works in some dude
I'm losing it. >> You you'd be the one you'd be the mastermind
behind it.
>> Now when you attract a man drunk
to a notel room >> this the way this girl digested that
rohypnol. The way she got drugged like that she was begging for
it. Okay. She Andrew Tate it would have been wrong for him not
to do it. Okay. He asks you if he can. >> Would have been
wrong for him not to choke her out while she was like beating
against his arm with her hands to let him make him let her go.
All right. It would have been wrong for him to stop at that point.
>> In the bed with you and you say yes and you kiss him
and he kisses you and you concerned if there's a there's a level
of involvement
in the building crime that will be a rape that cannot be allowed
simply legally. We can't allow someone to cause their that much.
And here's why socially. Here's why this is all extremely important.
If you let woman cause their then you have what I consider we're
already here. We're already in this situation.
You have woman who know that rape is endurable enough and tolerable
enough that they will put >> endurable enough and tolerable
>> put themselves in the situation to cause
>> okay JF just JF just bites that bullet Jeff is like
okay if JF was born in the US with like the same brain he would
be very similar to Max okay he's going to he's going to munch
down those bullets right there. Okay. Women know that they can
endure a and so they will sometimes put themselves in a situation
where they will be
that's an that that's a tough position to take and hold. I'll
I'll give it to him. Okay. >> So that they can later brag
I've been by and rotate. you're going to have basically a race
toward well okay if that's the game if if a book of accusations
will bring you fame and if for the moment you can escalate a
career let's say for 10 years not talking about the rap just
from your networking with that person and then turn it into a
rep and it gives you an extension of 10 years on your career
with a book with the money that comes with it etc.
I dude, who's buying the book? I don't even know. We're like
people are hypothesizing that you could like make a massive book
out of this or sorry, you could you could sell massive numbers
of books out of this. Like literally the thing everybody wanted
to read is already on the table to discuss. I don't think I don't
think there's like anything to really go with here. I five book
reviews. Five review book. Wait, what? Dude, no. No, no. I'm
just saying I don't think the sales are going to be impressive
and it's like already getting reviewbombed. I just I don't think
I feel like personally Lauren just wanted to like get this all
off her chest and then go away now man. I wonder if it's like
a perfect recollection if she let leave leaves stuff out too.
She off her audience. She's off like every audience now and he's
saying it's technically not that is a preconceived setup. That
is kind of the thing he's saying. Yes, >> we are already
at the point where
it certainly crossed the mind of Lauren Southern then at that
moment where she is supposed to have said no. And I'm going to
believe it on I'm going to believe her on her words. Okay. That
she said some kind of no
just just before the of Andrew Tate was coming into her [__]
as they were kissing passionately
>> and drugged and on alcohol.
>> She said no
one right now. >> I'm going to believe her on this. If
if I if I am to consider that this is a I will have to consider
that she is guilty of it. And the problem is someone cannot commit
a crime against themselves
because then then you enter the narcissistic problem of the modern
female the me too movement and everything. It's like well okay
we know the gimmick you guys you women are going out there causing
to occur.
You are keeping it in on the record in your mind. I said no.
So that you can use it 10 years down the line once the effective
use of the the the consensual version of your story >> is
of no use to you. >> So if JF is all Quebecqua JF is the
average Quebec. Yes, that is true. Thank you Dire for backing
that up. I know. I know. I know. So Lauren Southern
uh having having basically failed at
continuously
holding the pillars of the right wing has made a rap rush with
destiny and started to want to be this ex rightwinger.
Like all of like all literally all alright females ever except
those that disappeared when she dis >> Okay. No, he's talking
about other people who disappeared. I It's just weird. It's weird
for him to say that like these other ones who have disappeared
and he just laughs
>> like like
all literally all alight females ever >> except those that
disappear. When she dis when she disappears you don't get to
see the reversal toward liberalism. But basically uh any talking
heads of the right wing that is a female has failed at sustaining
uh her altright talking points for and so they either disappear
in the dark and they don't talk about it too much or they do
like Lauren and they try to get this second layer narcissistic
extension into the oh well this was disinformation I was the
victim of disinformation. So, so they they they reframe themselves
as victims.
>> Um, we have to find a solution as a society
to what do we do with this? Because I wouldn't want guys to be
subjected to the murder version of my story. I wouldn't want
people to be the victim of constant entrament.
But by giving any sort of attention to Lawrence Sutter and even
by just granting that this is legally you >> this is uh
this is what I mean when he says like it's not going to be criminal
is he's going to say the downsides of charging this is wrong
for society are so bad the knock on effects of accepting this
is a will be disastrous for society so we cannot do so that's
his libertarian argument for like why some must occur. You are
creating a market. You're creating a market for entrapment. That
is what's happening. We are creating a market for entrapment
that young females are looking at right now and they're like,
"Oh, so that's the >> Yes. The downside of allowing of
criminalizing this is now women will just do this intentionally.
Okay. >> I have to go get by some >> No, no, no.
If you charge this as rape, then women know that they can blackmail
men in dubious consent situations and all men and now suddenly
like you've created an incentive for women to call things after
the fact is going to be >> creepy super rich guy that has
some power either in Hollywood or or like in the rotate on the
internet
whatever I have to I have to get by a guy like this. I have to
ent trap them into the room, but then I have to just say no at
the very end. And so that way 10 years down the line, that's
that's value. That that's a million dollar book. That's a $10
million book. >> Dude, do you think she's going to make
more than 20,000 more than $50,000 off that book? She might be
able to get
maybe. I'm not even certain of that to be honest with you.
>> We don't want this. and and and basically common law
gives us the tools to not have this
because you have the principle of unclean ant.
So if you have
committed actions in line with a crime, you cannot ask for damages
you cannot ask for damages that stem from your criminal act.
This is extremely well expressed by Tom Hanks
>> again. Um, hold on. Just to be clear, unclean hands
legal. So, the doctrine of unclean hands is an equitable defense
that prevents a party from obtaining relief from the court if
they have engaged in misconduct or unethical behavior related
to the subject matter of the litigation. Essentially, it means
that the party seeking equitable relief must have acted fairly
and ethically in the matter at hand. Oh, wait. That is different.
Hold on. That is different. This is different than the explanation
I've looked at before. Uh, no. JF's right. You know what? JF
WJF,
at least that's what that says. Quotable defense that bars relief
to a party who's engaged in inequitable behavior including fraud,
deceit, unconscionability or bad faith. Okay. Okay. WJF
>> in the movie. >> That's my misunderstanding. I
think >> he has a beautiful sentence about it. >> Yeah.
No, it doesn't apply here, but he is arguing why it applies here.
Obviously. Okay. Obviously, I don't necessarily agree to take,
but I'm going to enjoy it. Okay. You can't take it away from
me. But anyways, leaving that aside, you cannot ask to be reimbursed
like some employment insurance
for engagement in a criminal pursuit. That is what Tom Hanks
says.
Once you engage in the criminal pursuit, you're harming other
people or you're harming yourself.
But don't come and and beg for the damages after. But the problem
here is we have the unclean ends doctrine in court. So that protects
say and rotate against a civil claim by Lawrence Southern but
we should have the unclean. So, I guess JF is arguing that at
any point, like at what point, let's say this went on for two
hours, at what point does Andrew Tate have to stop? If Lauren
Southern says stop, right? He's arguing basically that as it
started. Okay, now you can't call that. I would say that's only
the case if he stopped shortly after she said no,
right? like okay the hypothetically gave is like he penetrates
her and then like oh it stops stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop or something like that right
like you can forgive some amount of leadup there but obviously
the the allegation is that he kept having sex with her against
her will for hours or for for some amount of time right that
she kept going in and out of consciousness
>> doctrine reading goofy goofy goofy >> and we should
have the unclean hands doctrine when reading these [__]
>> who are telling these stories years down the line with
unverified viable information,
incomplete information. And we already know that the Laurens
Southern claims are incomplete because we have Andrew Tate coming
out and saying, "Maybe I should write my own book about how Lauren
Southern after this supposed
>> wrote to me many times
saying uh saying I I want to see you again. When do we see ourselves?
When do we see each other again? So, you're going to ask me to
believe that you've been right. And and she she she is claiming
that it wasn't one of these cases of unclear. I really really
said no. I really really locked my leg. >> I really >> together.
Uh but then So, so you got Okay. So, so by >> Wait, she
didn't say that. That's from the That's from the Rolo thing.
>> Your account. You got >> Isn't it? I thought that
was the Rollolo thing. Or is that in Lauren? I don't think that
was in Lauren's thing. I think that's in the Rollolo texts. But
you you you send messages to the guy who raped you one year
down the line. We see each other again. And with the history
of Lauren Southern, we know what's happening. It's it's really
bipolar disorder. Maybe borderline personality disorder. She
is psychotic.
>> Fear paying.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. >> Hold on. >> Maybe
this fine regarded fellow can write a book about how he didn't
his wife. But if he did, >> well, and she is constantly
>> There are some murders that can be justified. That must
happen.
>> And I've seen I've known these women, by the way. I've
had these women in my life. They will drain all of your energy.
We even have now her ex in Australia, you know, the Fed. Literally,
she had a baby with a fed and then she kidnapped the baby and
stole it from >> Um, and ran back to Canada. Um, now this
guy is coming out. He had sent DMs to Rolo Thomas. >> What's
up Darius? >> To confirm that the story that she tells
>> Hold on. Do I have this do I have this picture of Darius
still? I don't >> this stack is at least a consistent story
because she has she he describes that story. >> Probably
not. >> Apparently, according to these DMs from her Australian
ex, >> we're talking to your contemporary
>> that Andrew Tit did happen. She cries sometimes about
it. She then sucked Tommy Robinson's dick as a kind of bounce
back from this. So So Tommy Robinson brings you to get by and
rotate probably in exchange of some
bail him out. No Darius I could totally get like viewers off
of Darius. Darius is uh Darius is swimming in views right now
on the with the ice beside and stuff. I'm just I'm doing this
coverage. Uh if I finish this and you still want to talk in like
I don't know 40 minutes, an hour or something, we can talk. Oh,
he's taken away. Oh, Tommy Robinson disappeared for so we cannot
check on Lauren for that afternoon. Oh. Uh, and so she says that
Andrew Tate was telling her, "I'm going to call I'm going to
call Tommy. We're going to have him. We're going to go get him.
Don't worry about it." >> Oh, but Darius is discord.gg/jstlk.
>> So, that kept the supervision of Tommy Robinson away.
But what was Tommy Robinson doing? He was probably on Coke like
he is all the time. So then she sucks Tommy Robinson's to try
to emotionally recover from the endator.
She says she regrets because Tommy Robinson is married but she
sucked his and then she she tries to reform herself in her media
image by going to Destiny and according to that Australian man
who has a child with her. >> Oh, I do like that I called
that he read all the Rolo tweets before the Rolo like emails
before he I even said it right. Just the locking your legs together
Yes. According to that Australian man, she also had a child with
Destiny. So, she had a daughter with Destiny. Uh, and who knows
where that daughter is. So, this is a woman who bounces. Yeah,
I recognize this behavior. >> Oh, he's going to totally
just uncritically say, "Yeah, no, had a daughter with It's like
with these women, it's very easy to have if you're at the right
moment in the right situation, but they're going to bring a world
of trouble to your life such that I would tell you this isn't
even worth it. This isn't even worth it. Let me tell you, because
holy
do they bring problems. So, going back to the the narrative of
Lauren Southern. So, she gets to Andrew Tate carried by Tommy
Robinson.
crypto discussions and rotate as his crypto bros basically uh
slaving away for him and we're gonna create these coins and look
we made that much money on these coins. So um and basically and
rotate is kind of opened about the idea that this is scam crypto.
It's >> no he was never open about that. The other guy
was open about that >> to scam his audience or scam people
in general. And uh and at some point you know they get carried
away and at some point Tommy Robinson disappears so isn't available
to chapron the the relationship
and uh and Rotate reports that in these times she was very inord
toward him. She was like starruck and loving him and affectionate.
And he says do you want to go to a bar? And she says I knew at
that point that I had a chance to get away. So, I asked when
when is Tommy coming back? >> Wait, I think did she say
I knew I had the chance to get away? I think she said like, "Oh,
I started feeling weird about this and I could like I know now
that I could have gotten away." I think is what you said. >> And
he says, "We're going to get Tommy on the >> Star Struck
by Andrew Tate." I think I think she did describe knowing that
he was like confident, he was attractive, he was seemed kind
and stuff, right? >> We're going to get him. Don't worry.
But would you like to go to the bar while we wait for him? And
then they go to the bar, they consume drugs, they consume
and she presents it in writing as all I remember is I I just
drank just one one something and I was totally out of it. But
then later in the text she says I was really like passed out
drunk.
>> Okay. So you you're telling me that you blanked from
your first sip of a in a >> Uh-oh. He misses the implication
here. >> You just blanked on exactly what you've been consuming.
In other words, you don't want to reveal the the true nature
of your conscious consumption of alcohol. You have self inebriated
while being with Andrew.
Now, she wants to frame the story as a so she tells you and then
then I just wake up and I'm in a hotel room, but it's like no,
you >> that's not what it was. She remembered throwing
up in the bathroom. She remembered like nearly passing out on
a couch, right? There's a lot of stuff in between. You weren't
put in a cage by Andrew Tate to be carried to a hotel room. You
tried to blank exactly at the moment where we could see that
ultimately you were a drunk woman consenting to going into a
hotel room. This cheap trick of
one minute I I'm
>> What? Okay, let's just be real.
Why wouldn't she consent to be taken back to her hotel room,
right? at a bar just drinking my first drink and oh the other
>> sex with juices should be its own crime. >> Jesus
43 bucks.
What the [__]
>> Greatest whitest tipped 43 bucks. >> I I I haven't
even there >> but yeah that that's something. See I I've
avoided that trouble. There's lots of trouble I love to give
myself in but not that one. So, uh, you you're asking us basically
to accept that you have no remembering of partying with the rotate,
getting one drink after another. No, you woke up in front of
the toilet in a hotel room and you were just barfing. I don't
believe this. Absolutely.
Designed to hide the fact that you were loving toward him. You
got the offer to get in a hotel room and you consented to it.
You went from a bar to a hotel room with him. And then then then
it's the bed moment. So we have two telling of that story. We
have Laurens's writing about it and then we have her Australian
boyfriend DM uh which uh which lays it out in in a certain way.
So according to Lauren in in her writing she says I don't want
to go into the detail but you can guess according to her Australian
ex-boyfriend and rotate. So they had kissed they so so what the
two versions tell us is Lauren accepted to be kissed by Andrew
Rutate. Lauren laid on the bed. She said she was tired and rotate
started kissing her and she kissed back and before that he had
asked can I come into the bed with you and she had said yes and
and the rotate then according to the Australian version of the
story and rotate uh tried to penetrate her in the ass while she
was uh laying on her >> I don't think that's in that. We
just read that. We just read that. Hold on. We literally just
read it. Enter her from behind is all that said. That's That's
Is that Do they only do doggy in Quebec if it's going in number
two or what? What are we doing here? JF, what are you revealing
about yourself here? >> She said no. And she locked her
her legs together and then he started choking her
uh and saying open your legs and then he had with her. Uh according
to her written story, the component of this is not predominant.
>> It's not predominant. What the what is he saying? >> Uh
it is it is more let >> Why is he adding his own things?
He's adding his own stuff. He's adding his own spices. Crazy
>> to the imagination.
But according to the written version of it, uh Tate would have
tried many times to uh advance on her and she said no. And it
wasn't a case where the no was unclear. She said a very very
clear series of no and physically attempted to resist. But she
understood then that she hadn't realized that there was a point
of no return in a point where my words would not matter
>> What? That's not the part of the story you're supposed
to laugh at. >> So this is this is the story. So So this
is the written story. And >> this is crazy. >> Her
Australian ex. So what do we have here? We have this situation.
should have been destroyed. >> He's laughing at the wrong
parts >> in the case of the murder. We have someone who
has collaborated to her own rap if it's a and this is the telling
of the story without any
without any of the alternative telling from Andrew Tate because
of course clearly Lauren is using all of the tricks she can to
hide away certain things. So her whole blackout moment I don't
believe it. The way she tells her consent moment, it's always
with a to give the reader. She always completes it with something
else. Like, but I was very drunk. Like, oh, I said yes to him
being in the bed, but I was very drunk.
Come. >> There's no level of drunk at which you stop understanding
that a hotel with a guy is for it's not for a business. >> That's
her hotel room there. He took her back to her hotel room. That's
her hotel room. Now, should she have said don't come in? Yeah,
probably.
>> There's no level of drunk at which this fact goes out
of your head if it >> also I believe she says this much
in the story. I believe even when she goes to the club that she's
like, I easily could have got it's not like this guy like you
know I don't I think I could have gotten out of there like even
at some later >> Does then we need some AI some AI for
>> that will explain. Yes, he's trying to have with you.
>> Leave now if you don't have if you don't want to have
sex. So basically we have someone who has been accessory to her
own which is why I say by the doctrine of unclean ends at this
point you have to say yes technically it's a
but I will not ever judge anyone for this because
because you have participated to so many items of consent that
one could argue that you are more responsible for this situation
than in route eight even is because a oh come in the bed in the
hotel and oh I'm going to kiss you and then you say a little
no. The problem is there is a lot of women out there who will
say no at the very end and it's kind of their white privilege.
It's a white privilege thing. This whole idea that oh I am such
a queen
okay
now for he he had my he had my uh interest. Okay. But now he
has my attention. I got to see I got to see this. How do we get
here? I reserve I reserve the ultimate right at the last minute
to change my mind. And you have to be kind of narcissistic and
and to to think that way. But that is uh that is also how how
women show up in narcissistic case of murder control or murder
mastermind where where they they manipulate a guy to commit a
murder. It's like never their fault and they they all no matter
their involvement, their level of causing the thing, they it
it doesn't get in their head that it's ultimately their fault
and that basically the guy the guy that committed the murder
by your order and by your charm and by your romance and by your
invitation and by your help is barely a murderer. You are you
are the mastermind of the murder. So >> again, we've we've
gone through Yeah, this doesn't it doesn't work. But >> I
hope that I have made a case because I knew that there were some
libertarians. People are confused. They're like >> again
if she if he had like if she'd said no and he'd like entered
her like right as she said no and then eventually she's like
no no you have to stop. You have to stop. You have to stop. Right.
And then he stopped. He was like oh I'm sorry. But from the Australian
version of the story why didn't why didn't JF include the line
from the Australian version of the story where Andrew Tate says
yeah I you are you gonna do about it? Why didn't he include that
line? That's in those DMs, is it not? Hold on. So what? I you
you can't do anything about it. Off is in this version of the
story what he said.
Why? If JF's going to take these versions of the story and like
and operate with them like openly include that part. >> Something
in my instinct tells me that she's a stupid but I can't quite
put
how how do I reconcile my belief in the fact that no means and
the fact that I don't consider that she got raped? Well, the
way you have to say it is she technically got robbed, >> but
it's one of those.
>> But she was literally asking for it so badly that we
can't prosecute it. Okay, that's that's his position. >> Must
occur to punish the to punish the behavior of entrapment, to
punish those women who put themselves so in such clear situations
that they can only expect that to happen. And we're faced with
many problems in society. This this story is told to me again
and again by guys across the planet. Okay, seems to be female
universal. >> If you guys missed it, okay, if you guys
missed it, if you're just tuning in late and you didn't watch
the start of this, this is the quote, okay, this is the quote
from this this segment that sent us down this path in the beginning.
>> and then they try to ride on that trouble. And as a
libertarian, it's hard. It's hard to say, well, she said no,
so it's right. And I I would like to take you by the hand tonight
and convince you that basically and this is my philosophical
libertarian position.
There are some rights that must occur. It's still it's still
hitting just as hard as the first time I heard it. This is my
philosophical
This is my philosophical libertarian position.
Some must occur. I It hits hard every time. It's so good. It's
so
they approach her, they get too close to and she says, "Oh, no.
I'm not ready for they step back. They leave her alone." And
this has been told to me by so many guys that this this is I'm
sure this is >> Hold on. He's about to say something awesome
again. >> Uh she comes back a day later and she's like,
"Why why didn't you keep uh insisting? Why didn't you insist?
Why didn't you rob me?" Basically, this has been told again and
again from regular guys talking to me on the internet to Louis
CK in his uh in some of his comedic performance.
It seems that women
they love this fantasy thing. In fact, psychological studies
show that they they enjoy these fantasies, these submission fantasies.
And ultimately
I I believe there are some women probably who are so who are
they like they like the idea of denial so much and they get off
from it >> that basically a guy like can rotate can only
them. >> He just keeps dropping them in. He just keeps
dropping him in >> that basically they are they are testing
what if I get him in the bed with me then then will he me what
if I kiss him but then say you know will he me and it's the ultimate
narcissist ultimately dreams of being such a valuable object
that and couldn't control himself he couldn't help but me someone
has captured the contradiction here between libertarian values
and and this concept Matt Bo was saying I don't believe her and
he did it. That's my take. Law of non contradiction.
>> I don't believe her. And he did it. That's my take.
Law of non-contradiction be damned.
>> People listening to this uh this story, they know there's
something wrong with it, but they can't put their finger on it.
And >> there that's what I expected, by the way. That's
what I expected Nick Fentes's take to be. That's why I thought
Nick Fentes went soft on this. Okay. I thought that was gonna
be his take. Like,
listen. I don't Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Don't
I have I think I think I literally have a video for this. Hold
on. Don't I literally have a video for this?
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is
it? Oh, I don't have it, do I? [__] There's a Fentes
video where he talks about this. >> And I hope that what
I told >> I don't have it. What does Fentes say? I think
he just said she's like a lying [__] But yeah, I
expected him to do the these people deserve rape and I disavow
rape, but these people deserve it. I thought he was going to
say I listen nobody else just Lawrence Southern like you you
deserved it. I believe I believe you and also don't prosecute
Andrew. >> You put uh your finger >> That's what
I thought his take was going to be. >> It is a case of
someone who participates so much to her own self-damaging behavior
that she should not be considered credible. Although although
you may believe in all of the facts that she's spouting, all
of these facts are ultimately incriminating for her and her making
her
ends dirty. Now, of course, she will go on and try to frame herself
as a victim. Now,
what she writes in this substack is uh you know, you ultimately
it was my fault. So, she's trying to to frame it as, "Oh, I'm
not claiming it was a" and this is so typical,
this kind of personality that's so self-absorbed. They want everything.
They want, "Oh, well, yeah, take me." But but I didn't quite
call it a and I have acknowledged my responsibility in parts
of the it's like at this point you are taking us through
through a a kind of ride for hell you know these uh these carnivals
you get into the mind of Lauren Sutton it's like it's like what
at this point you are just causing trouble in >> Lawrence
Southern is a 1900's silent film villain. Okay,
>> society with your broken mind.
>> You are trying to frustrate the right wing. You're trying
to frustrate the the racialist. They will say, "Oh, well, you
were with a black man. You you're trying to frustrate the leftist
by saying, "Oh, you know, I kind of caused that also.
You know, I'm I'm going to acknowledge my bit of responsibility.
I had I had the choice not to go to the bar." And it's like,
bro, you don't even have a beginning of understanding of how
stupid you are. And Nick Fantes got it absolutely right. She's
just a stupid
She is the epitome of it. You You haven't be >> Nick's
going to be eating off of that shout out for the next like year.
God damn it. >> Understand the layers of trouble that you
are for society because you're so broken inside. Holy. And this
all the Let's go back. Let's rewind here. Okay. And yes, >> this
whole thing comes out of a book that she's publishing called
This Is Not Real Life. And oh, what is real life? Here I am in
the Canadian wilderness with my kidnapped baby from Australia
after my bipolar my my borderline crisis against my boyfriend
who happened to be a fed. This is not real life.
This is a woman thing to say this thing
because the way Lauren Sutn has decided to market herself going
forward is, "Oh, I was trapped in in this community.
This is not real life." You'll hear that for a moment all the
time. This idea that
>> oh uh I'm not my real self. I wasn't my real self. That
is uh that is actually something that is cringe. Okay. I didn't
get to be my real self with this person. I always I'm always
not real life
>> and and she has apparently many chapters about the whole
idea that oh yeah when uh you know viral success is not reality
but I'm sorry this is real life. I'm like I take offense for
the internet. Madame at this point I'm not even offended by for
for the alt-right or for the for for whatever group you would
you would consider she's talking against. I'm I'm insulted for
the internet
because yeah, the money was real though, says DK Shadow. Exactly.
Those are real human beings that admired you for what you had
to say. Those are real human beings that you try to climb socially.
What is all this behind JF to the left of his head? Uh, this
looks like if you're trying to build a Rubik's cube out of paper.
There's like a template for a Rubik's cube you build out of paper.
I think that's what this is that you like put together with glue
sticks and stuff and it's like a real paper Rubik's cube. That's
what that looks like to me off the top of my head if I had to
guess. I've like done that that thing before. It's all shaded.
So maybe it's like a multi- color Rubik's cube or some I don't
even know. Multi-dimensional Rubik's cube or something, but I
it doesn't I mean it looks like it goes for multiple things.
>> I don't know. >> Those are real human beings that
you've entrapped in your distortions of reality.
Those are real human beings that were sending you 10 50 bucks.
So to the contrary, this is real life. The internet is real.
I mean, and
like our whole stick is that, oh, it's it's filled with pathological
personalities. Well, maybe you have a way of attracting >> Maybe
it's something else. Maybe it's some other puzzle thing. Maybe
it's just a puzzle thing. >> Pathological personalities
around you because I'm not a pathological personality.
And you've never came to me in 2017 18. You You were just hanging
out with different people, but you're hanging out. That's Oh
my god. It's going to be the same Tim Pool thing.
I wanted to All of these guys All of these guys have told stories
about how Lauren was like such a
that all of them are offended that she didn't come to them. All
of the All of the most disgenic right-wingers are just like,
"You know what? She should have me." If you're going to be a
it's unfair to not be a to me. She has unclean hands. Okay. She
was a for everybody else and not me. Unclean >> The people
that get you excited. And what are those people? They're coke
addicts. They're in trouble. They live completely disrupted lives.
So you are seeking pathology. You are actively trying to get
toward it. Now if you if you had done a stream with JF, you wouldn't
have had the end tape the end routted hotel room treatment. But
you don't want to do this. You want to be with the weirdos. You
want to be in the bed with this trans person. Then in a hotel
room with Andrew Tate, then sniffing Coke in the UK with Tommy
Robinson. You are a troublemaker and a trouble seeker and you
are responsible. >> Who's the trans person? I am lost again.
>> Everything that has happened. In fact, this is not revelations
of the right wing because th those those characters that you've
hung out with are at best at the edge of a true dissident right.
Like if I was actually mad at somebody for noting me, I feel
like I would hide that. That would be shameful. I don't know
why these guys all come out here and they're like, "Yeah, uh,
well, if you me, I wouldn't have you. I wouldn't have raped you,
you know, but you didn't want to hang out with me. You want to
hang out with Andrew Tate and get raped. I I would be too ashamed
to do this >> wing movement. They are at best at the intersection
with the kosher Zionist movement, mainstream movement. They are
at best gatekeepers for a true dissident ride. Now, this is not
real life. It's not what you would say if you had hung out with
the real ones. You know, the real ones like me, the real ones
like Arval.
Uh, you know, Arval, I'm sure if if he's standing on his porch
tonight, I'm sure the the the the landscape that you see behind
him is pretty much this. It's pretty much what you call now real
life. So, you've chosen this not real life and it's not the internet
and it's not communities and it's not the right wing even. You've
just chosen to go with the most extreme pathological people because
you know what, Lauren, it's where you belong.
You are a woman up in the head. >> Whoa. Oh, I had to block
her because when she started having with Destiny, somehow JF
became a wife beater and a
>> I feel like
he really took Dude, if you called if you said he killed his
wife, he took that personally. Okay. >> Not surprising.
Not surprising.
She touches Destiny, gets inseminated by him, and suddenly she's
she's against me and making false claims against me. I feel like
that was the whole internet >> See, this is not real life.
It's still >> I don't think the whole internet destiny
to think you >> not real life you're into. It's still not
real life and it won't ever be real life for you because you
carry so much
[__] up theness inside of you that you will you will
spread it wherever you >> And so you have comforted yourself
into thinking, oh well, all of these altrate
>> Didn't he pretty much softly admit that he did? He did
like an OJ thing, right? >> Is there bathological,
>> but you're telling yourself a lie still because people
like me have been standing for the truth and I've been living
healthy lifestyles
for a decade now and we live on the internet. >> How did
his wife supposedly die? He took his he had a wife who was honestly
like a ward of the state I think and like uh like she was actually
I believe still like under her parents' guardianship or something
and married her like actually like extremely loy like borderline.
Okay. And then he I don't know what happened. He like had some
fights with her and he drove her out to the woods and just let
her go for a walk one day.
Right.
By the way, this was not the first mentally disabled person that
he had gotten into a relationship with. Not the first one. >> It
is real life and there are real people in the regular chat. And
the way the way you dismiss these people by >> she Mama
JF is a free spirit >> running away taking their money
is
>> Is she still alive? I think so. Somebody went on 4chan
and posted that they saw her at like a 7-Eleven or something,
right? People kind of just suspect that was JF though. disgusting
in the end. It's disgusting that you are will the truth and I've
been living healthy
>> for a decade now and we live on the internet and it
is real life and there are real people in the regular chat and
the way the way you dismiss these people by running away taking
their money is absolutely disgusting in the end. It's >> in
the end. I thought he was being racist, but he just said in the
end >> that you are on this constant drainage of everything
in your life, men through the internet, through donation, you're
always consuming, always attracting toward you, but realizing
less and less in life with it. And at this point, you're spinning
in nothingness. At this point, you won't make any meaningful
contribution except reinterpret
the broken story that you have in your mind about yourself and
about your history.
And anything you say going forward is just a big loss of everyone's
time. Because if you're a young female rising, you think you're
going to read Lauren Sutton and say, "Ah, it's not worth it."
Like, do you think that the young Lauren Sutton would have would
have read a book from an old female saying, "Don't be attracted
by these weird movements. It's not worth it. It's disinformation.
It's it's coke. It's MDMA."
No. Young Lauren Sautturn would have thrown herself into all
of it because young Lauren Sern wants all of the trouble. She
wants to be ruled by Andrew and she puts herself in. >> I
don't know about that one, but I do think that if there was a
glamorous lifestyle that people could go for and they thought
they could have everything, right? The trad life and the glamorous
lifestyle and verality and all this, then I think they would
chase that. I think Lauren Southern would have chased that. I
don't know why we have to add this. She wants to get raped. possible
position to be ruled by. So ultimately your words of warning
>> will not serve the truth. They will not serve the next
generation. They will only serve to
yourself into a a kind of reformed psychology, reformed history
and a revisionist history of what you did and who you are. But
what you did and who you are is you exploited people and you
you are so tuned to what people think of you. You are so tuned
to the social truth that you'll never find anything true going
forward in your life because you care too much. You care so much.
Your value is you have a external locus of control. Okay? You
need validation. You need everybody else. Okay? JF
JF doesn't need anybody. JF can be alone. Okay? He's a self-made
man. He's an internal locus of control. He doesn't need validation
from anyone else. And that's the difference between you and JF,
Lauren. Okay? JF would never JF could easily not be by Andrew
Tate. >> That within a year, >> not even he wouldn't
even break a sweat. >> You're willing to rotate from I'm
getting by and rotate to I'm sucking Tommy Robinson's. I'm getting
inciminated by Destiny.
You are constantly monkey. You're monkey branching between men.
>> He's he's weaving different right-wing theories together
now. Oh my god. >> You only see yourself through their
eyes. You are nothing without them. and you will start getting
old. You will start getting less fertile. And because you will
not have shown an ability for any sort of loyalty to a single
one of these men that you would have chosen, you will end up
an extremely bitter woman trying to get the attention and not
quite getting it because it's never going to be as big as the
first wave. It's never going to be as big as Lauren Sutton filming
Borderless. It's always going to be smaller and smaller and they're
always going to attract losers and betas and reformed people.
Ohas, I have been uh I have been disinformed by the alt-right.
I have been disinformed by vaccine propag antivaccine
And you're only going to identify yourself through the denial
of what you think you shouldn't be. But again, you're stuck in
this social conception of yourself.
Lily has the right words to frame it. She says, "Give me a break,
ladies. Have some self-respect and stop airing your dirty laundry
online. Boring, embarrassing, and false." >> If JFK, if
JF says, if he actually cooks here and says, "Lily Gatis, you
specifically should read this book because this is going to be
you in 5 years. Just so you know, you should actually read this
book. This is just you in 5 years." That I might have to give
it to him. Okay, I might have to. Nick Fantes says she is a stupid.
It's >> He didn't do it.
>> he didn't do it. >> Well said. Well seen. I've
heard that Richard Spencer had nice words about the whole situation.
I not >> uh yet seen that clips. >> Richard Spencer,
I believe, said, "Shut up. Nobody cares."
>> And we have Rotate who has come out and who has said,
"Hey, look."
>> All right. I think that's it for his unique commentary
on this. That was not bad. Listen, JF's always good content,
okay? He might not be a good person, but he's always good content.